With the FIZ loyalty program, you get rewarded just for having a mobile plan. You know, for texting and stuff. And if you're not getting rewards like extra data and dollars off with your mobile plan, you're not with FIZ. Switch today. Conditions apply. Details at fiz.ca. At Algoma University, your future has no limits. Here, you can go further, in the classroom, in the field, and well beyond. We provide personalized education, cultural fluency, and training for in-demand careers. We don't just prepare you for the future. We prepare you to change it.
有了 FIZ 忠诚度计划，您只需拥有一个移动套餐即可获得奖励。比如发短信之类的。如果您现在的移动套餐没有提供额外流量和现金抵扣等奖励，那您就不是 FIZ 的用户。立即切换吧。适用相关条款。详情请见 fiz.ca。在阿尔戈马大学，您的未来没有极限。在这里，无论是在课堂上、实地考察中，还是在更广阔的领域，您都能走得更远。我们提供个性化教育、文化素养培养以及热门职业培训。我们不仅为您准备好迎接未来，更让您有能力改变未来。
Plus, Algoma has the most affordable tuition in Ontario. Make the most of your university experience. Go further. Apply to Algoma University today. Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support and for a more detailed list of content warnings, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. Saturday August 10 1963 was a stormy winter's night in Perth with heavy rain and thunder.
此外，阿尔戈马大学拥有安大略省最实惠的学费。充分利用您的大学时光。走得更远。立即申请阿尔戈马大学。我们的剧集涉及严肃且往往令人痛苦的事件。如果您在任何时候感到需要支持，请联系您当地的危机中心。如需获取保密支持的建议电话号码以及更详细的内容警告列表，请查看您应用程序或我们网站上本剧集的节目说明。1963 年 8 月 10 日星期六，珀斯经历了一个暴风雨般的冬夜，伴随着大雨和雷鸣。
But Carl and Wendy Dowd were heading out anyway to go to a party just a kilometre from their home in Dalkeith. The suburb was just south of Netherlands, which had been upended by the Australia Day shootings six months earlier. The initial panic after that event had somewhat calmed down by now. Even though the shooter hadn't been apprehended, the fact that there hadn't been any shootings since meant that locals had started to relax ever so slightly. Carl and Wendy had hired a second-year university student to babysit their eight-month-old while they were out. Shirley MacLeod was a diligent science major
但卡尔和温迪·多德夫妇还是决定出门去参加一个聚会，地点就在他们位于达尔基斯的家附近，仅一公里远。这个郊区位于内德兰兹以南，而内德兰兹在六个月前的澳大利亚日枪击案中遭受了重创。那次事件后的最初恐慌现在已经有所平息。尽管枪手尚未被抓获，但自那以后再未发生过枪击事件，这意味着当地居民开始稍微放松了一些警惕。卡尔和温迪雇了一名大学二年级的学生来照顾他们八个月大的孩子，而他们则外出参加聚会。雪莉·麦克劳德是一位勤奋的理科生，
who was filling in for her friend, the Doud's usual sitter. She had won a scholarship to attend university and her plan was to become a social worker. There are so many people who need help, she had once told her father. Shirley had been devastated by the murder of her friend John Sturkey in the Australia Day shootings. They had shared some of the same uni lectures. Carl and Wendy felt confident leaving their baby in Shirley's care. She was a kind, conscientious girl who'd brought her textbooks with her. As the baby was sleeping, Shirley was hoping to get some study done. The Douds said goodbye, then headed out to their party. It was 2am when they arrived home, happy and in high spirits after a fun night out. Wendy went straight to the bedroom to check on the
她正在替她的朋友，也就是多德夫妇通常雇用的保姆代班。她曾获得奖学金进入大学，计划成为一名社会工作者。她曾对父亲说，有太多人需要帮助了。雪莉对她在澳大利亚日枪击案中失去朋友约翰·斯塔基感到非常悲痛。他们曾一起上过几门大学课程。卡尔和温迪很放心地把孩子交给雪莉照顾。她是一个善良、尽责的女孩，还随身带了教科书。趁孩子睡觉时，雪莉希望能做些功课。多德夫妇告别后便前往聚会。凌晨 2 点，他们回到家，度过了一个愉快的夜晚，心情很好。温迪径直走进卧室去查看
baby, while Carl headed to the lounge room where Shirley had been sitting when they left. The lounge was well lit and warm warm as Shirley had the heater running. A teacup and saucer sat on the coffee table and the turntable was spinning with a record that had long since finished playing. Shirley's shoes sat neatly on the floor while she sat on a small couch, her head slumped. Carl assumed she must have dozed off while studying as she was still holding a pen and notepad. Then Carl noticed that Shirley's clothes and face were covered in blood.
孩子，而卡尔则走向了客厅，那是他们离开时雪莉坐的地方。客厅里灯火通明，因为雪莉开了暖气，所以很暖和。咖啡桌上放着一个茶杯和茶托，唱片机上正转动着一张早已播放完毕的唱片。雪莉的鞋子整齐地放在地板上，她坐在小沙发上，头垂着。卡尔以为她一定是学习时睡着了，因为她手里还拿着一支笔和一个记事本。接着，卡尔注意到雪莉的衣服和脸上满是鲜血。
Clearly visible in her forehead was a bullet hole. She had been murdered, he was gripped by the terrifying fear that the killer might still be in the house. He raced to the bedroom where Wendy was tending to their eight-month-old son. He was awake and smiling, clearly unharmed. Carl told Wendy what had happened before quietly phoning the police. The Dowd family remained barricaded in the bedroom until help arrived. The Dowd family remained barricaded in the bedroom until help arrived. While the case couldn't be definitively linked to the killing spree in late January, investigating officers had their suspicions.
她的额头上清晰可见一个弹孔。她被谋杀了，他被一种恐惧感所笼罩，担心凶手可能还在屋子里。他冲进卧室，温迪正在照顾他们八个月大的儿子。孩子醒着，正在微笑，显然没有受到伤害。卡尔告诉温迪发生了什么事，然后平静地报了警。多德一家一直躲在卧室里，直到救援人员赶到。多德一家一直躲在卧室里，直到救援人员赶到。虽然这起案件无法明确与一月下旬的连环杀人案联系起来，但调查人员对此已有怀疑。
The victims in all of the murders were random and had been targeted in homes. All had been killed with a single shot to the forehead from a.22 calibre weapon. Perth was still scarred by the Australia Day massacre and the sudden re-emergence of the shooter sent the city into a new wave of panic. The killer was dubbed the Netherlands Monster. Young women stopped taking on jobs and people opted to stay at home with their families rather than go out at night. Shirley's murder became the police department's top priority. Almost none of the Doud's neighbours had heard anything suspicious that night, though one man said he'd heard a particularly loud clap of thunder that could have been a gunshot.
所有谋杀案的受害者都是随机选择的，且都是在住所内遭到袭击。所有受害者都是被 0.22 口径武器近距离射击额头而亡。珀斯仍笼罩在澳大利亚日大屠杀的阴影中，枪手的突然重现让整个城市陷入了新一轮的恐慌。凶手被称为“内德兰兹怪物”。年轻女性不再接受夜间工作，人们选择待在家里陪伴家人，而不是晚上外出。雪莉的谋杀案成为了警察局的首要任务。多德夫妇的邻居中几乎没有人听到那天晚上有什么可疑动静，尽管有一名男子说他听到了一声特别响的雷声，那可能是一声枪响。
The timing of it had aligned with Shirley's suspected time of death. A squad of 50 detectives door-knocked homes throughout Daukeethe and Nedlands, interviewing more than 8,000 residents. Police recovered a single unidentified fingerprint from the home, which didn't match anyone who was known to have visited or lived there. It was decided that police would take the fingerprints of all males aged between 14 and 60 in the Perth metropolitan area, starting with Netherlands and Coddersloe. Police had also extracted the bullet from Shirley MacLeod's head, which had distinct markings they could use to identify the murder weapon if
那声响的时间与雪莉推测的死亡时间相吻合。一支由 50 名侦探组成的队伍对达尔基斯和内德兰兹的住户进行了逐门走访，采访了超过 8,000 名居民。警方在屋内提取到一枚身份不明的指纹，该指纹与任何已知到访过或居住在那里的人都不匹配。警方决定对珀斯大都会区所有 14 至 60 岁的男性进行指纹采集，首先从内德兰兹和科茨洛开始。警方还从雪莉·麦克劳德的头部取出了子弹，子弹上有独特的痕迹，如果
it was ever found. William and Cecilia Keener were an elderly couple who resided in the South Perth suburb of Mount Pleasant. Their daily habit of taking a walk together every afternoon had recently been disrupted by the heavy rain Perth was experiencing, but on Friday August 16, the sun was shining. The pair set off sometime after 3pm. They liked to stroll down the road where they lived, which was called Hawken Street, to the banks of the Swan River. The couple kept a little fishing boat down there, which they would check on, and they'd also stop to chat to neighbours they met along the way. On this particular Friday, they turned left upon reaching the river and walked up towards Canning Bridge. As they ambled along, they noticed that one of the trees along the path had several limbs
凶器被找到，他们可以用这些痕迹来识别。威廉和塞西莉亚·基纳是一对住在南珀斯芒特普莱森特郊区的老夫妇。他们每天下午一起散步的习惯最近因珀斯的大雨而中断，但 8 月 16 日星期五，阳光明媚。两人在下午 3 点多出发。他们喜欢沿着居住的霍肯街散步，前往天鹅河岸。这对夫妇在那里有一艘小渔船，他们会去查看一下，沿途还会停下来与遇到的邻居聊天。在这个特定的星期五，他们到达河边后向左转，朝着坎宁桥走去。当他们漫步时，注意到路边的一棵树有几根树枝
snapped off. Car tracks were visible in the ground leading towards it. The couple wondered if there had been an accident and whether the driver had been hurt. After walking about 500 metres along the riverbank, William and Cecilia turned left at Rookwood Street to make a loop home. Pale pink native wildflowers were growing in abundance all along the street, and Cecilia decided to pick some. As she reached up to take a sprig, something on the ground slipped and brushed Cecilia's knee. It was the butt of a rifle. Shocked, Cecilia pushed the firearm back under the bush before telling William, there's a rifle here. After taking a look for himself, William suggested they take it home to prevent it from falling into the wrong hands. As neither of them held gun licenses, Cecilia
断了。地上有通向那里的车辙。这对夫妇想知道是否发生了事故，司机是否受伤。沿着河岸走了大约 500 米后，威廉和塞西莉亚在鲁克伍德街左转，准备绕道回家。街上到处长满了淡粉色的原生野花，塞西莉亚决定采摘一些。当她伸手去拿一枝花时，地上的东西滑了一下，擦到了塞西莉亚的膝盖。那是一把步枪的枪托。塞西莉亚大吃一惊，把枪推回灌木丛下，然后告诉威廉：“这里有一把步枪。”威廉亲自查看后，建议他们把它带回家，以免落入坏人之手。由于他们都没有持枪证，塞西莉亚
opposed this plan. Instead, when they got home, she reported the discovery to the police. the discovery to the police. It was a 22 gauge Winchester rifle, different from the Lithgow single shot rifle used in the Australia Day shootings. Still, it was worth investigating. Officers searched the entirety of Rookwood Street but didn't find a single cartridge. However, the rifle was still loaded with a single bullet. When police test-fired the weapon, they found that the copper-nosed bullet had the same markings as the one taken from Shirley MacLeod's body. They had found the weapon used by her killer. It turned out that the rifle was registered to a former Olympic swimmer named Garrick Acne.
反对这个计划。相反，当他们回到家后，她向警方报告了这一发现。那是一把 22 口径的温彻斯特步枪，与澳大利亚日枪击案中使用的利斯戈单发步枪不同。不过，这仍然值得调查。警官搜查了整条鲁克伍德街，但没有找到一颗弹壳。然而，步枪里仍然装有一发子弹。当警方对武器进行试射时，发现铜头子弹留下的痕迹与从雪莉·麦克劳德体内取出的子弹痕迹相同。他们找到了凶手使用的武器。事实证明，这把步枪登记在一位名叫加里克·阿克内的前奥运会游泳选手名下。
Garrick had spent the last month and a half overseas. When he'd returned home just a few days earlier, he'd discovered that his Winchester rifle was missing from the bedroom cupboard where he kept it. Nothing else had been taken from the home, including a second rifle that was stored in another room. Garrick had reported the rifle stolen on Tuesday, August 13. Police were interested in the way that the rifle had been left in the bush on Rookwood Street. It hadn't been carelessly discarded somewhere, as though the killer was tossing it aside permanently. Instead, it had been hidden inside thick vegetation,
加里克在过去一个半月里一直在海外。几天前他刚回到家，就发现他的温彻斯特步枪从存放它的卧室柜子里不见了。家里没有丢失其他东西，包括存放在另一个房间的第二把步枪。加里克在 8 月 13 日星期二报告了步枪被盗。警方对步枪被遗弃在鲁克伍德街灌木丛中的方式很感兴趣。它并没有被随意丢弃在某处，好像凶手打算永久扔掉它一样。相反，它被藏在茂密的植被中，
something that someone might do if they planned to retrieve it at a later date. Investigators took another rifle back to the bush where Cecilia Keener had found it and tied it there tightly with fishing line. Police requested permission from the residents of the house opposite to set up a 24-hour-a-day lookout in their backyard which spanned an entire block. That way, the bush with the rifle could be kept under constant surveillance. the bush with the rifle could be kept under constant surveillance. The residents gave their permission and agreed not to tell anyone about the top secret operation. A trap to catch the killer was set. Now all the police had to do was wait. Over the next two weeks, police kept a 24-hour-a-day surveillance running in the property opposite the rifle, with at least one officer remaining on the lookout at all times.
这可能是某人计划在以后取回它时会做的事情。调查人员将另一把步枪带回塞西莉亚·基纳发现它的灌木丛中，并用鱼线将其紧紧系在那里。警方请求对面住户的许可，在他们跨越整个街区的后院设立 24 小时监视点。这样，藏有步枪的灌木丛就可以保持在持续监视之下。居民们表示同意，并承诺不对任何人透露这项绝密行动。抓捕凶手的陷阱已经设好。现在警方所要做的就是等待。在接下来的两周里，警方在步枪对面的房产内进行了 24 小时监视，始终至少有一名警官在值守。
It was a particularly cold and wet winter, which made their job even more difficult. After a fortnight passed with no sign of the shooter, investigators decided they needed to do something to lure him back to his weapon. With the cooperation of local reporters, an article had been planted in multiple newspapers that stated police working the Shirley McLeod case would turn their attention to the suburb of Mount Pleasant by the end of the coming week. On the morning of Saturday August 31, one of Perth's papers ran a story about how police would be fingerprinting Mount Pleasant residents very soon. That night, Constable Bill Hawker was on surveillance duty in Rookwood Street. It was cool and slightly overcast, a pleasant change from the near constant rain of the
那是一个特别寒冷潮湿的冬天，这让他们的工作更加困难。两周过去了，枪手毫无踪影，调查人员决定必须采取行动引诱他回来取武器。在当地记者的配合下，多家报纸刊登了一篇文章，称负责雪莉·麦克劳德案的警方将在下周末前将注意力转向芒特普莱森特郊区。8 月 31 日星期六早上，珀斯的一家报纸刊登了一篇关于警方很快将对芒特普莱森特居民进行指纹采集的报道。那天晚上，比尔·霍克警官在鲁克伍德街执行监视任务。天气凉爽，略有阴天，与过去两周几乎持续不断的降雨相比，这是一个令人愉快的变化，
past two weeks, and Bill wondered if the killer would finally be spooked enough to try retrieving his rifle. He took up his post at 6pm alongside a colleague named Peter Skihan. Several hours later, Constable Hawker was keeping watch alone while Constable Skihan rested inside a tent set up for the officers in the backyard across from the trap. Constable Hawker could hear music from a nearby pub, and occasionally couples would stroll along Brookookwood Street on their way home from a night out, but so far no one had taken any interest in the trap. At 1.15 every night, the streetlights on Rookwood Street went out. If the killer decided to return
比尔想知道凶手是否终于会被吓到而试图取回他的步枪。他在下午 6 点与同事彼得·斯基汉一起上岗。几个小时后，霍克警官独自值守，而斯基汉警官在后院为警官们搭建的帐篷里休息。霍克警官能听到附近酒吧传来的音乐，偶尔有情侣在结束夜生活回家的路上沿着鲁克伍德街漫步，但到目前为止，没有人对陷阱表现出兴趣。每天凌晨 1 点 15 分，鲁克伍德街的路灯会熄灭。如果凶手决定回来
for his rifle, he would most likely do so after that time when the street was at its darkest. When the lights switched off like clockwork, Constable Hawker braced himself and stared even more intently at the dark street in front of him. Suddenly, a grey-blue Holden sedan appeared and slowly pulled up at the curb opposite the trap. The road was steep so Constable Hawker could only see the top of the car. His initial response was to wonder if it was a couple looking for a quiet spot to spend time together. But then the driver's side door partly opened, with the person behind the wheel holding at a jar.
取他的步枪，他很可能会在那之后，即街道最黑暗的时候行动。当路灯准时熄灭时，霍克警官振作精神，更加专注地盯着前方黑暗的街道。突然，一辆蓝灰色的霍顿轿车出现，慢慢停在陷阱对面的路边。道路很陡，所以霍克警官只能看到车顶。他最初的反应是想这是否是一对寻找安静地方共度时光的情侣。但随后驾驶座的车门半开着，开车的人把门虚掩着。
Several moments passed, then the door opened more widely. A man got out and stood still in the car's doorway. Almost certain that he was looking at their suspect, Constable Hawker rushed to the tent to wake his colleague. They had to act quickly. The rifle was tied to the bush and the killer would surely flee if he went to retrieve it and discovered the trap. Nor did they want the killer to be armed by the time they were able to reach him. Constable Hawker leapt over the property's fence, closely followed by Constable Skean. Crouching down in front of the bush was a man wearing a heavy overcoat. As he heard the sound of the police officer's footsteps running towards him, he turned around to face them. The two police officers grabbed the man in the overcoat, who struggled
过了片刻，车门开得更大了。一名男子下车，静静地站在车门口。霍克警官几乎确定他看到了嫌疑人，于是冲向帐篷叫醒了他的同事。他们必须迅速行动。步枪被系在灌木丛上，如果凶手去取枪时发现陷阱，肯定会逃跑。他们也不希望凶手在他们赶到时已经武装起来。霍克警官跳过围栏，斯基汉警官紧随其后。灌木丛前蹲着一名穿着厚大衣的男子。当他听到警官跑向他的脚步声时，他转过身面对他们。两名警官抓住了这名穿着大衣的男子，他进行了挣扎。
against them. Constable Hawker pulled out a set of handcuffs and cuffed the man's wrists, then used a second set of cuffs to secure the man to a fence. The suspect mumbled incomprehensibly in a muffled voice as he was arrested. mumbled incomprehensibly in a muffled voice as he was arrested. In clearer light, the officers could see that he carried a small pencil torch and was wearing a pair of women's leather gloves. He had short dark hair, a broad nose, and a notable scar on his mouth from surgery to repair a cleft lip palate. A search revealed that he was carrying a pair of women's underpants
霍克警官掏出一副手铐将男子的手腕铐住，然后用第二副手铐将他固定在围栏上。男子被捕时，嘴里含糊不清地嘟囔着。在更明亮的光线下，警官们可以看到他带着一把小铅笔手电筒，戴着一副女式皮手套。他留着深色短发，鼻子宽大，嘴唇上有一个明显的疤痕，那是修复唇腭裂手术留下的。搜查发现他口袋里装着一副女式内裤，另一个口袋里装着一张剪报。他在剪报上乱涂了一些地址和电话号码。霍克和斯基汉警官呼叫了增援，嫌疑人被转移到警察总部接受审讯。他很快被确认为 32 岁的埃里克·埃德加·库克，一个西澳大利亚警方非常熟悉的人。案件档案稍后回来。感谢您通过收听本剧集的赞助商来支持我们。比如移动套餐的额外流量和现金抵扣。您不是 Fizz 的用户。立即切换。适用条款，详情请见 Fizz.ca。在阿尔戈马大学，您的未来没有极限。
in one of his pockets and a newspaper clipping in another. He had scribbled some addresses and phone numbers on the clipping. Constables Walker and Skean called for backup and the suspect was transferred to police headquarters for questioning. He was quickly identified as 32 year old Eric Edgar Cook, a man who was already very well known to Western Australia Police. Case file will be back shortly. Thank you for supporting us by listening to this episode's sponsors. like extra data and dollars off with your mobile plan. You're not with Fizz. Switch today. Conditions apply, details at Fizz.ca. At Algoma University, your future has no limits.
一个口袋里装着东西，另一个口袋里装着一张剪报。他在剪报上潦草地写了一些地址和电话号码。沃克警官和斯基恩警官呼叫了增援，嫌疑人被转移到警察总部接受审讯。他很快被确认为32岁的埃里克·埃德加·库克，一个西澳大利亚警方非常熟悉的人。案件档案稍后回来。感谢您收听本期节目的赞助商。比如移动套餐可以获得额外流量和折扣。如果您还没使用Fizz，今天就切换吧。适用相关条款，详情请见Fizz.ca。在阿尔戈马大学，您的未来无限可能。
Here, you can go further, in the classroom, in the field, and well beyond. We provide personalized education, cultural fluency, and training for in-demand careers. We don't just prepare you for the future. We prepare you to change it. Plus, Algoma has the most affordable tuition in Ontario. Make the most of your university experience.
在这里，无论是在课堂上、实地考察中，还是在更广阔的领域，您都能走得更远。我们提供个性化教育、文化素养培养以及热门职业培训。我们不仅为您准备好迎接未来，更让您有能力改变未来。此外，阿尔戈马大学拥有安大略省最实惠的学费。充分利用您的大学时光。
Go further. Apply to Algoma University today. Thank you for listening to this episode's ads. By supporting our sponsors, you support Casefile to continue to deliver quality content. On Friday October 15 1948, Cook had committed his first break-in at the age of 17. In 1948, Cook had committed his first break-in at the age of 17. He forced his way into a flat in Perth's CBD while its resident was out and stole a torch and a small clock.
走得更远。立即申请阿尔戈马大学。感谢您收听本剧集的广告。通过支持我们的赞助商，您支持 Casefile 继续提供高质量的内容。1948 年 10 月 15 日星期五，库克在 17 岁时犯下了他的第一次入室盗窃案。1948 年，库克在 17 岁时犯下了他的第一次入室盗窃案。他强行闯入珀斯中央商务区的一间公寓，在住户外出时偷走了一把手电筒和一个小钟。
He also opened several bottles of wine and poured them all over the resident's clothing. When police later attended the crime scene, they found Cook's fingerprints all over the empty bottles. Though they didn't match anyone in the system, they added the prints to their files. A few weeks later, Cook broke into another home. Angry after he found nothing he wanted to steal, he trashed the property by pulling all of the clothing from the wardrobes and cutting it with a knife. He also slashed some bedding and a pillow before taking chocolate from the fridge and feeding it to the couple's pet goldfish. His final act was to start a fire in the living room. The resident returned to find his flat in flames, and although firefighters were able
他还打开了几瓶葡萄酒，把酒倒在住户的衣服上。当警方后来到达犯罪现场时，他们在空酒瓶上发现了库克的指纹。虽然它们与系统中的任何人都不匹配，但他们还是将指纹添加到了档案中。几周后，库克闯入了另一所房子。因为没找到想偷的东西而感到愤怒，他把衣柜里的衣服全部扯出来，用刀割碎，以此毁坏了房产。他还割破了一些床上用品和一个枕头，然后从冰箱里拿出巧克力喂给这对夫妇的宠物金鱼。他的最后一个举动是在客厅放火。住户回来发现公寓陷入火海，尽管消防员能够
to save the home, the damage cost almost $20,000 in today's money. Two weeks later, Cook broke into another home and stole 20 shillings, an engagement ring, a watch, and a fountain pen. He later tossed the jury out of fear of being caught. Not long after that, at Christmas time, Cook was asked by a friend to house sit for her while she and her husband were away. Despite having a key to the property, Cook smashed a window to cover his tracks and decided to set fire to the residence. He piled all of his friends' clothing on the bedroom floor then coated it in fly spray
挽救房屋，但损失相当于今天的近 2 万美元。两周后，库克闯入另一所房子，偷走了 20 先令、一枚订婚戒指、一块手表和一支钢笔。后来，他因害怕被抓而扔掉了珠宝。不久之后，在圣诞节期间，一位朋友请库克在她和丈夫外出时帮忙看家。尽管有房子的钥匙，库克还是砸碎了一扇窗户以掩盖行踪，并决定放火烧毁住所。他把朋友所有的衣服堆在卧室地板上，然后喷上杀虫剂
as an accelerant. Yet, his plan ultimately failed when he couldn't find any matches. A week later, on New Year's Eve, Cook celebrated the beginning of 1949 by breaking into an empty flat in the CBD. He used some cellophane and a candle that he found inside to light a fire. When the resident came home at 12.35am, she found her bedroom completely destroyed by the blaze. Cook continued to commit more break-ins across the city during the first months of 1949, leaving fingerprints behind when he stole whatever cash he found along with women's
作为助燃剂。然而，他的计划最终失败了，因为他找不到火柴。一周后，即除夕夜，库克通过闯入中央商务区的一间空公寓来庆祝 1949 年的开始。他用在里面找到的一些玻璃纸和蜡烛点燃了一场火。当住户在凌晨 12 点 35 分回家时，发现她的卧室被大火完全摧毁了。库克在 1949 年的前几个月里继续在全市范围内进行更多的入室盗窃，在偷走他发现的任何现金以及女性
underwear. He also lit more fires at other addresses. Once he defecated in a toy cot that belonged to a child. In early March, Cook broke into a house just north of the CBD, entering via the back door. Cook knew the property, as he'd delivered groceries there previously while working for a market. It was late at night and the residents were in their beds asleep. The now 18-year-old Cook was more emboldened and no longer just targeted empty homes.
内衣时留下了指纹。他还在其他地址放了更多的火。有一次，他在一个属于孩子的玩具婴儿床里排便。3 月初，库克闯入中央商务区以北的一所房子，从后门进入。库克熟悉这处房产，因为他以前在为市场工作时曾送过杂货。当时已是深夜，住户们正在床上熟睡。现年 18 岁的库克胆子更大了，不再仅仅针对空房子。
Using a torch to see, Cook found a purse and took it to the bathroom to search through. As he was rummaging through the purse, a man entered the bathroom and found him. As he was rummaging through the purse, a man entered the bathroom and found him. It was one of the residents who'd been woken by his wife after she heard Cook creeping about. Cook claimed to be a neighbour who had drunkenly entered the property by mistake and gave his first name. His lies weren't believed. When the resident tried to grapple with him, Cook fled. Police tracked him down a week later and matched his fingerprints to two previous break-ins. He was charged and taken before the courts. Cook was convicted on two counts of stealing, four counts of arson, and seven of breaking and entering. He was sentenced to three years in prison with the recommendation he'd be released
库克用手电筒照明，发现了一个钱包，并把它带到浴室里翻找。当他在翻找钱包时，一名男子进入浴室发现了他在里面。当他在翻找钱包时，一名男子进入浴室发现了他在里面。那是住户之一，他在妻子听到库克潜入的声音后被叫醒。库克声称自己是一名醉酒后误入房产的邻居，并报出了自己的名字。他的谎言没有被相信。当住户试图与他搏斗时，库克逃跑了。警方在一周后追踪到他，并将他的指纹与之前的两起入室盗窃案进行了匹配。他被指控并被带上法庭。库克因两项盗窃罪、四项纵火罪和七项入室盗窃罪被定罪。他被判处三年监禁，并建议他在几个月后
on parole after a few months so that he could be rehabilitated. Cook's father was an abusive alcoholic who terrorised his entire family but focused most of his rage on his son. Cook had been born with a cleft palate and lip, a common birth defect that made his father hate him. He beat his son and verbally abused him. Once, when Cook had tried to stop his father from beating up his mother, his father punched him so badly he suffered a skull fracture. Students at school had also bullied and ostracised Cook, mocking his appearance and a distinctive speech impediment that was the result of his birth defect. One time, Cook's mother saw her son standing in front of a mirror, violently pulling at his scarred lip. Desperate for an escape, Cook had started wandering the streets of Perth and stealing from his teachers, neighbours and peers as a child. There were concerns that hard time
获得假释，以便他能改过自新。库克的父亲是一个虐待成性的酒鬼，他恐吓全家，但将大部分愤怒集中在儿子身上。库克天生患有唇腭裂，这是一种常见的出生缺陷，导致他父亲憎恨他。他殴打儿子并对他进行言语辱骂。有一次，当库克试图阻止父亲殴打母亲时，父亲把他打得头骨骨折。学校里的学生也欺负和排斥库克，嘲笑他的外表和因出生缺陷导致的独特语言障碍。有一次，库克的母亲看到儿子站在镜子前，用力拉扯他那有疤痕的嘴唇。渴望逃离的库克开始在珀斯的街头游荡，并从小就开始偷窃老师、邻居和同龄人的东西。有人担心坐牢
would only serve to further criminalise the first-time offender. The parole board ultimately decided to release Eric Addaquook in August 1949, agreeing that his brief stint in prison had been enough to scare him straight. They felt that Cook had committed crimes because he was socially isolated and saw the acts as a way to gain notoriety and friendships. Although he had been an intelligent student, his education was hindered by his behavioural problems and his father, who forced him to leave school at the age of 14. Cook started working from then on, passing most of his earnings onto his mother and a stealing to supplement his own income. From then on, Cook worked a series of menial jobs.
只会进一步使这个初犯者犯罪化。假释委员会最终决定在 1949 年 8 月释放埃里克·埃德加·库克，同意他短暂的监狱生活足以让他改邪归正。他们认为库克犯罪是因为他被社会孤立，并将这些行为视为获得名声和友谊的一种方式。尽管他曾是一名聪明的学生，但他的教育受到了行为问题和父亲的阻碍，父亲强迫他在 14 岁时辍学。从那时起，库克开始工作，将大部分收入交给母亲，并靠偷窃来补充自己的收入。从那时起，库克做了一系列卑微的工作。
He was an accident-prone person and his employment record was impacted by repeated accidents. Once his face was badly scalded by steam. Another time he fell and damaged his spine, leading to a week in hospital. Cook's many injuries included multiple head injuries. He would often slip and hit his head, resulting in concussions and further fractures. Following his release from prison, he started working at a confectionery company and joined a church. Overall, his life improved. His probation period concluded two years later on August 15, 1951. To celebrate his return to freedom, Cook travelled east across the country to Melbourne,
他是一个容易出事故的人，他的就业记录受到反复事故的影响。有一次他的脸被蒸汽严重烫伤。另一次他摔倒伤到了脊椎，导致在医院住了一周。库克的许多伤病包括多次头部受伤。他经常滑倒并撞到头，导致脑震荡和进一步骨折。出狱后，他开始在一家糖果公司工作并加入了教会。总的来说，他的生活有所改善。他的缓刑期于两年后的 1951 年 8 月 15 日结束。为了庆祝重获自由，库克向东横跨全国前往墨尔本，
where he enlisted in the Australian Army. During his training, he became an excellent marksman, but was discharged three months later when the army learnt of his previous offending. Cook returned to Perth and started working as a truck driver. returned to Perth and started working as a truck driver. The short, dark-haired man had never had much luck with women, but in 1953 he met a young woman named Sally Lavin. They married in November of that year and settled in the inner eastern suburb of Rivervale. Less than two years later, the couple already had two sons. But Cork's new law-abiding image and family man lifestyle didn't put a stop to his criminal activities. In 1953, he broke into the home of some fellow church members and stole from them.
在那里他加入了澳大利亚军队。在训练期间，他成为了一名出色的神枪手，但在三个月后，当军队得知他之前的犯罪记录时，他被开除了。库克回到珀斯，开始做卡车司机。回到珀斯，开始做卡车司机。这个身材矮小、深色头发的男人在女性面前一直不太走运，但在 1953 年，他遇到了一个名叫萨莉·拉文的年轻女子。他们于同年 11 月结婚，并在内东郊的里弗维尔定居。不到两年，这对夫妇已经有了两个儿子。但库克新的守法形象和顾家生活方式并没有停止他的犯罪活动。1953 年，他闯入了一些教会成员的家中并偷窃了他们的财物。
His fingerprints led to his arrest and he was placed on a good behaviour bond. In September 1955, two months after the birth of his second son, Cook had set his sights on another woman. When he found out she was playing in a hockey tournament two hours south of Perth in Bumbury, he stole a car to stalk her there. Cook rolled the car along the way, suffering a broken sternum plus face and knee injuries. The incident led to him being charged with assuming control of a motor vehicle. Cook was sentenced to two years' hard labour for the theft as well as an additional six months for breaking his good behaviour bond. His young wife Sally had to raise their two children alone
他的指纹导致他被捕，并被处以良好行为保证金。1955 年 9 月，在第二个儿子出生两个月后，库克盯上了另一个女人。当他发现她正在珀斯以南两小时车程的班伯里参加曲棍球锦标赛时，他偷了一辆车去那里跟踪她。库克在途中翻了车，导致胸骨骨折，脸部和膝盖受伤。这起事件导致他被指控非法控制机动车。库克因盗窃罪被判处两年苦役，并因违反良好行为保证金被额外判处六个月监禁。他年轻的妻子萨莉不得不独自抚养他们的两个孩子，
as a single parent but still made sure to visit Cook in prison. She stood by her husband throughout throughout his incarceration. He was back with his family by Christmas 1956. Following Eric Edgar Cook's second release, he appeared to mostly stick to the straight and narrow, focusing on working hard to support his growing family. He and Sally would eventually go on to have five more children, giving them a total of seven, four boys and three girls. On Monday January 25 1960, Cook's reputation was tarnished once again when he was arrested for loitering in a park in Lathlane, one of Perth's inner eastern suburbs. He was sentenced to a month's incarceration in Fremantle Prison. While there, police questioned him about a horrific murder that had been committed the previous month, the brutal killing of 22-year-old heiress and socialite Gillian Brewer.
作为单亲妈妈，但仍然坚持去监狱探望库克。她在丈夫服刑期间一直支持他。到 1956 年圣诞节，他回到了家人身边。在埃里克·埃德加·库克第二次获释后，他似乎大多走上了正道，专注于努力工作以支持他日益壮大的家庭。他和萨莉最终又生了五个孩子，总共有七个，四个男孩和三个女孩。1960 年 1 月 25 日星期一，库克的名声再次受损，当时他因在珀斯内东郊之一的拉斯莱恩的一个公园里游荡而被捕。他被判在弗里曼特尔监狱服刑一个月。在那里，警方询问了他上个月发生的一起可怕的谋杀案，即 22 岁的女继承人和名媛吉莉安·布鲁尔被残忍杀害的案件。
During Cook's break-ins, he was known to steal women's underwear and masturbate with it. This deviant criminal history led police to label him a, quote, sexo and wonder if he could be behind the young woman's murder. Cook denied having anything to do with the crime, claiming he was home at the time, and his wife Sally supported this alibi. After that, Cook was still occasionally cited by the police for peeping Tom and minor theft defences, but they never suspected him of murder. Not until more than three and a half years later, in the early hours of Sunday September 1 1963, when he went to the suburb of Mount Pleasant to collect the rifle used to kill university student
在库克的入室盗窃过程中，他以偷窃女性内衣并用其自慰而闻名。这段离经叛道的犯罪历史导致警方给他贴上了“性变态”的标签，并怀疑他是否是这名年轻女子谋杀案的幕后黑手。库克否认与该罪行有任何关系，声称案发时他在家，他的妻子萨莉也支持这一不在场证明。此后，库克偶尔仍会被警方以偷窥和轻微盗窃罪传唤，但他们从未怀疑他谋杀。直到三年半后的 1963 年 9 月 1 日星期日凌晨，他前往芒特普莱森特郊区去取那把用于杀害大学生
Shirley MacLeod. Following Cook's arrest, he was transferred to the Criminal Investigation Branch headquarters. He was chatty with the officers, readily admitting that he'd broken into some homes that night in the wealthy western suburbs of Claremont, Peppermint Grove and Mossman Park. He said he'd stolen more than £22 in cash from those properties. Cork explained that he'd spotted the rifle a few days earlier while he'd been driving down Rookwood Street in his work truck. He'd stopped to adjust the truck's load and noticed that someone had stashed a rifle in some nearby bushes. Cook had decided to come back to take it. His plan was to sell it to make some cash. He adamantly denied having anything to do with Shirley MacLeod's murder three weeks
雪莉·麦克劳德的步枪。库克被捕后，被转移到刑事调查分部总部。他与警官们谈笑风生，欣然承认那天晚上他闯入了克莱蒙特、薄荷林和莫斯曼公园等富裕的西郊的一些住宅。他说他从那些房产中偷走了超过 22 英镑的现金。库克解释说，几天前他在驾驶工作卡车沿鲁克伍德街行驶时发现了那把步枪。他停下来调整卡车的货物，注意到有人把一把步枪藏在附近的灌木丛中。库克决定回来把它拿走。他的计划是把它卖掉换点钱。他坚决否认与三周前雪莉·麦克劳德的谋杀案有任何关系。
earlier. He claimed that he'd been at a bowling alley until 8pm, then he went straight home and stayed there for the rest of the night. Two sergeants were dispatched to Cook's home, where they explained to his wife Sally that he had been arrested for breaking and entering. They had a search warrant and they wanted to ask her a question. Where had her husband been on the evening of Saturday August 10? Sally Cook told them the truth. He had been out until very late that night.
他声称他一直待在保龄球馆直到晚上 8 点，然后直接回家并整晚待在那里。两名警长被派往库克的家，向他的妻子萨莉解释他因入室盗窃被捕。他们有搜查令，想问她一个问题。她丈夫在 8 月 10 日星期六晚上在哪里？萨莉·库克告诉了他们真相。那天晚上他出去直到很晚。
them the truth. He had been out until very late that night. Back at the Criminal Investigation Branch headquarters, Eric Cook was told that his wife was refuting his alibi. He flatly refused to believe this, instead demanding that Sally be brought in to see him. Officers obliged and Sally was taken into the interrogation room where her husband sat. When she told him that she had in fact made the statement, he asked her why. Because it is the truth, Eric, and you know it, Sally replied. Sally replied. What do you think I should do now? Cook asked. Sally told him that decision was his to make. Not long after this, Cook borrowed a pen from a detective and began to write. On Saturday August 10, Cook had left home at 12.30pm and spent the afternoon bowling in East Perth. Later that night, he drove in his car to Cottesloe, then got out and wandered around on foot. When he spotted a fancy looking house, he walked in and helped himself to some coins lying around.
告诉了他们真相。那天晚上他出去直到很晚。在刑事调查分部总部，埃里克·库克被告知他的妻子反驳了他的不在场证明。他断然拒绝相信这一点，反而要求把萨莉带进来见他。警官们照办了，萨莉被带进审讯室，她的丈夫坐在那里。当她告诉他她确实做了那份陈述时，他问她为什么。萨莉回答说：“因为那是事实，埃里克，你知道的。”萨莉回答说。库克问：“你觉得我现在该怎么办？”萨莉告诉他，决定权在他自己手中。此后不久，库克向一名侦探借了一支笔，开始写字。8 月 10 日星期六，库克于中午 12 点 30 分离家，下午在东珀斯打保龄球。那天晚上晚些时候，他开车去了科茨洛，然后下车步行四处游荡。当他看到一栋看起来很豪华的房子时，他走了进去，顺手拿走了一些散落在周围的硬币。
he walked in and helped himself to some coins lying around. He opened up a wardrobe and saw a rifle, which he took along with a packet of bullets. Cook then drove to Dow Keith. By now, it was pouring rain while thunder rumbled across the sky. Cook claimed that he must have blacked out at this point because the next thing he knew he was trying to exit a house with the rifle in his hand. He felt as though he must have fired the weapon and when he learnt the next day about the murder of Shirley MacLeod in Dalkeith, he knew he was responsible. Investigators didn't believe Cook had blacked out for a second. However, they had their confession, and their case was bolstered by a cartridge case recovered from Cook's car. The case matched the rifle used to kill Shirley MacLeod.
他走了进去，顺手拿走了一些散落在周围的硬币。他打开一个衣柜，看到了一把步枪，他连同一包子弹一起拿走了。库克随后开车前往达尔基斯。此时，外面下着倾盆大雨，雷声在天空中隆隆作响。库克声称他此时一定失去了知觉，因为他记得的下一件事就是他正试图拿着步枪离开一所房子。他觉得他一定开了枪，当第二天得知雪莉·麦克劳德在达尔基斯被谋杀的消息时，他知道自己负有责任。调查人员不相信库克失去了知觉。然而，他们得到了他的供词，而且从库克的车里找到的一个弹壳加强了他们的案件。该弹壳与用于杀害雪莉·麦克劳德的步枪相匹配。
Late on Sunday September 1, police charged Eric Edgar Cook with murder. As Western Australia still had capital punishment in 1963, Cook was looking at a death sentence. Although the rifle didn't match the firearm used in the Australia Day killing spree eight months earlier, investigators had always suspected that whoever was behind Shirley's murder committed those crimes too. They just needed to prove it. Over the following days, they spent hours and hours with Cook questioning him about his other crimes. Just as he'd initially done when arrested, Cook openly admitted to breaking into homes throughout the western suburbs, but denied anything to do with the other murders.
9 月 1 日星期日晚些时候，警方以谋杀罪起诉埃里克·埃德加·库克。由于西澳大利亚在 1963 年仍有死刑，库克面临死刑判决。虽然这把步枪与八个月前澳大利亚日连环杀人案中使用的枪支不匹配，但调查人员一直怀疑雪莉谋杀案的幕后黑手也犯下了那些罪行。他们只需要证明这一点。在接下来的几天里，他们花了数小时与库克在一起，询问他关于其他罪行的情况。正如他被捕时最初所做的那样，库克公开承认闯入了西郊的住宅，但否认与其他的谋杀案有任何关系。
On the morning of Tuesday September 3, three officers took Cook on a tour past the Netherlands and Coddersloe addresses where John Sturkey, George Warmsley and Brian Weir had been shot. Cook's uncomfortable body language left no doubt in the officer's minds that he was responsible. When they stopped for lunch at a pub, one of the investigators stated, ''Cookie, you're going to hang. There's no two ways about that. You'll go to the gallows as a bloody coward for the way you shot those people. Your wife and your kids are going to be reading history about you as a cowardly mongrel who went to the gallows without letting the people know exactly what you've done.
9 月 3 日星期二早上，三名警官带着库克参观了约翰·斯塔基、乔治·沃姆斯利和布莱恩·威尔被枪杀的内德兰兹和科茨洛地址。库克不舒服的肢体语言让警官们毫无疑问他是凶手。当他们在一家酒吧停下来吃午饭时，其中一名调查人员说：“库克，你要被绞死了。这一点毫无疑问。你会因为你射杀那些人的方式而作为懦夫走上绞刑架。你的妻子和孩子会读到关于你的历史，说你是一个懦弱的杂种，在没有让人们知道你到底做了什么的情况下就走上了绞刑架。
So what are you going to do, Cookie? Go there like that? Or go there like a bloody gentleman? With that, Cook indicated that he was ready to make another confession. He took the officers on another tour through Perth, this time explaining everything he'd done on Saturday January 26. A police photographer accompanied them, snapping pictures at each location. First, Cook guided the group to a home in the suburb of South Perth, where he'd stolen a cream and yellow Holden from. The vehicle had been parked in the garage with the keys in the ignition, a common practice in
那么你打算怎么做，库克？像那样去死？还是像个绅士一样去死？”说完，库克表示他准备做出另一次供述。他带着警官们在珀斯进行了另一次参观，这次解释了他在 1 月 26 日星期六所做的一切。一名警察摄影师陪同他们，在每个地点拍照。首先，库克引导小组前往南珀斯郊区的一所房子，他从那里偷了一辆奶油色和黄色的霍顿车。这辆车当时停在车库里，钥匙插在点火开关上，这是当时珀斯的常见做法。库克在案发当晚使用这辆车作为交通工具，事后又把它还回了车库。车主甚至没有意识到它被拿走了，更不用说被用于那场臭名昭著的犯罪狂潮了。
Perth at the time. Cook used the car as his means of transport on the night in question, then returned it to the garage after. The car's owner hadn't even realised it had been taken, let alone used in the notorious crime spree. let alone used in the notorious crime spree. The Winchester single-shot rifle Cook used on Australia Day was also stolen. He'd found it in a wardrobe while robbing a home in Cottersloe. It had taken the owner five months to realise it was missing as he rarely used it. It was only when police were asking all gun owners to hand over their rifles for examination that he discovered it was gone. Cook took the officers through his actions at each separate crime scene, explaining how he'd attacked each victim. He'd first set his
更不用说被用于那场臭名昭著的犯罪狂潮了。库克在澳大利亚日使用的温彻斯特单发步枪也是偷来的。他在科茨洛抢劫一所房子时在衣柜里发现了它。主人花了五个月才意识到它不见了，因为他很少使用它。直到警方要求所有枪支所有者上交步枪进行检查时，他才发现它不见了。库克带着警官们回顾了他在每个犯罪现场的行动，解释了他如何袭击每个受害者。他首先将目光投向了罗威娜·里夫斯和尼古拉斯·奥古斯特，他在一辆停着的车里发现了他们。库克最初打算作为偷窥者观察他们，但随后他感到另一种冲动涌上心头。库克解释说：“就在那时，这种力量控制了我。这不是一种冲动，它比冲动更强烈。它是……就好像我是上帝，就像一件斗篷或一朵云笼罩着我，我必须……我必须使用它。”他向罗威娜和尼古拉斯开枪，在他们开车逃跑时打伤了他们。然后他闯入布莱恩·威尔和约翰·斯塔基各自的家中，在床上射杀了他们。最后，库克按响了乔治·沃姆斯利家的门铃，并在他开门时射杀了他。
sights on Rowena Reeves and Nicholas August, who he spotted in a parked car. Cook had initially intended to observe them as a peeping Tom, but then he felt another urge come over him. It was then that this power came over me, Cook explained. It wasn't an impulse, it was stronger than an impulse. It was… it was as though I was God, and it was like a mantle or like a cloud came over me, and I must… I must use that." He fired at Rowena and to Nicholas, injuring them as they sped away. He then broke into Brian Weir and to John Sturkey's respective homes and shot them in their beds. Finally, Cook rang the doorbell of George Warmsley's home and shot him as he answered it.
他盯上了罗威娜·里夫斯和尼古拉斯·奥古斯特，当时他发现他们坐在停着的车里。库克最初打算像个偷窥狂一样观察他们，但随后他感到另一种冲动涌上心头。库克解释说：“就在那时，那股力量笼罩了我。那不是一种冲动，它比冲动更强烈。它……就好像我是上帝，就像一件斗篷或一朵云笼罩着我，我必须……我必须使用它。”他向罗威娜和尼古拉斯开枪，在他们开车逃离时打伤了他们。随后，他闯入布莱恩·威尔和约翰·斯特基的家中，在床上枪杀了他们。最后，库克按响了乔治·沃姆斯利家的门铃，并在他开门时将其枪杀。
All of the victims were random. Cook described his mood as follows, I felt as though I was God or some person who was untouchable just having that rifle in my hand and doing what I had done, and I felt that no power could stop me. When asked why he'd attacked people at all, he replied, I just wanted to hurt somebody. After he'd finished, he pulled over on the Narrow's Bridge, which connects South Perth to the rest of the city, and tossed the rifle into the Swan River below. Police divers were able to retrieve the rifle from the river. It was still there seven months later, buried beneath 10 centimetres of silt.
所有的受害者都是随机选择的。库克这样描述他的心情：“我感觉自己就像上帝，或者是一个不可触碰的人，手里拿着那把步枪，做着我所做的一切，我觉得没有任何力量能阻止我。”当被问及为什么要袭击他人时，他回答说：“我只是想伤害某个人。”作案后，他将车停在连接南珀斯与市区其他地方的纳罗斯大桥上，把步枪扔进了下方的天鹅河。警方潜水员后来从河中打捞出了这把步枪。七个月后，它依然在那里，埋在10厘米厚的淤泥之下。
Cook was charged with two additional counts of murder for John Sturkey and George Warmsley, one count of attempted murder for Nicholas August, and one count of unlawful wounding for Rowena Reeves. From there, the floodgates opened. Cook began talking more and more about other crimes he'd committed over the past five years, with an intricate level of detail. He said that he'd broken into about 250 houses. After his early arrests where fingerprints led to his arrest, he'd started wearing a pair of leather gloves. He also stayed quiet so that no one would hear his distinctive muffled sounding voice. While he sometimes struck on weeknights, he typically offended on weekend nights because that was when he had time to himself, free from work and able to escape the demands of his family. He would wander the
库克因约翰·斯特基和乔治·沃姆斯利的谋杀案被额外指控两项谋杀罪，因尼古拉斯·奥古斯特被指控一项谋杀未遂罪，并因罗威娜·里夫斯被指控一项非法伤害罪。此后，一发不可收拾。库克开始以极其复杂的细节，讲述他过去五年里犯下的其他罪行。他说他闯入了大约250所房屋。在早期的逮捕中，指纹导致他被捕，之后他开始戴上一副皮手套。他还保持安静，以免被人听到他那独特而低沉的声音。虽然他有时会在工作日的晚上作案，但他通常选择在周末晚上，因为那时他有自己的时间，不用工作，也能摆脱家庭的束缚。他会徘徊在
streets of Perth after dark, walking through residential areas and back laneways all night long, sometimes not returning home until morning. Cook could often remember exactly what he had taken from each house and what he'd done while he was there. Often he would steal cars too. As many people left their cars unlocked with the keys in the ignition in those days, it was all too easy for Cook to hop into a vehicle, take it for a joyride, and either discard it or return it later. Detectives followed up at the addresses Cook claimed to have burgled. Some of the burglaries could be confirmed from reports made or the victims' own recollections.
珀斯的街道上，天黑后整夜穿梭于住宅区和后巷，有时直到早晨才回家。库克通常能准确记得他从每所房子里拿走了什么，以及他在那里做了什么。他经常也会偷车。在那个年代，许多人离开车时都不锁门，钥匙还插在点火开关上，所以库克很容易就能跳进车里，开出去兜风，然后再丢弃或归还。侦探们对库克声称闯入的地址进行了后续调查。其中一些入室盗窃案可以通过报案记录或受害者自己的回忆得到证实。
Others came as a complete surprise to the residents who had been entirely unaware that there had been a prowler in their home or that anything had been taken. Yet, Cook was able to describe their floor plans, furnishings and decor in great detail. He could name particular locations in the house where money had been hidden away or left out in the open. Of the roughly 250 burglaries Cook detailed, he was ultimately charged for 20. Cook said that he'd sometimes done other things while trespassing in other people's homes. Cook watched women through windows, broke into their houses and stole their underwear. women through windows, broke into their houses and stole their underwear. He was fixated with young women, angry with how rejected he felt by them and seeking a kind of vengeance against people who didn't even know him. In the early hours of Wednesday November 26 1958, he had assaulted a
另一些则让居民们感到非常惊讶，他们完全不知道家里曾有潜行者，也不知道有任何东西被盗。然而，库克却能详细描述他们的平面图、家具和装饰。他能说出房子里藏钱或放在明处的具体位置。在库克详细交代的约250起入室盗窃案中，他最终被指控了20起。库克说，他在闯入别人家时有时还会做其他事情。库克透过窗户偷窥女性，闯入她们的家中并偷走她们的内衣。他迷恋年轻女性，对她们给他的拒绝感到愤怒，并试图向那些甚至不认识他的人进行某种报复。1958年11月26日星期三凌晨，他袭击了一名
15-year-old girl named Molly McLeod after she woke during his burglary. Cook had admitted to more assaults of women within their own homes. He was behind the attacks against Alex Donkin, Carmel Reed and Ann Melvin. These women all survived, but others hadn't. Cook confessed to the unsolved murders of Panina Berkman and Lucy Madrill. The former came as a shock. Police had been certain that Panina's then-boyfriend was behind her killing. Cook said he'd broken into Panina's flat halfway through 1958 and had robbed her. He returned six months later armed with a knife stolen from a home in Wembley in Western
名叫莫莉·麦克劳德的15岁女孩，当时她在入室盗窃中醒来。库克承认在受害者家中还袭击过其他女性。他是针对亚历克斯·唐金、卡梅尔·里德和安·梅尔文袭击事件的幕后黑手。这些女性都幸存了下来，但其他人却没有。库克承认了帕尼娜·伯克曼和露西·马德里尔的未破谋杀案。前者令人震惊。警方曾确信帕尼娜当时的男友是杀害她的凶手。库克说，他在1958年中期闯入了帕尼娜的公寓并抢劫了她。六个月后，他带着一把从西珀斯温布利一户人家偷来的刀又回来了。
Perth. Cook claimed he'd been searching Penina's dressing table when he knocked something over and woke her. She screamed and he jumped on her, forcing his heavy weight down and strangling her with his hands. Panina tried to scratch him, which was when Cook pulled out the knife and stabbed her. He later threw away the knife after fleeing the scene. Just as he'd done with Panina Berkman, Cook had broken into Lucy Madrill's flat previously before returning and taking her
库克声称他当时正在搜查帕尼娜的梳妆台，不小心碰倒了东西，把她吵醒了。她尖叫起来，他扑向她，用沉重的身体压住她，并用双手勒死了她。帕尼娜试图抓他，这时库克掏出刀刺向了她。他在逃离现场后扔掉了那把刀。就像对待帕尼娜·伯克曼一样，库克之前也曾闯入露西·马德里尔的公寓，之后又回来夺走了她的
life. He was able to take police to her home and explain every step of what he'd done and how her body was left. While taking another trip with detectives through the streets of Bayswater, Cook admitted that he'd tried to hurt women in other ways. He pointed out a spot where he'd run 20-year-old Glenis Peake down in a stolen Holden sedan. His description of the stolen car, where it was dumped and the damage to it, all matched the facts of the case. Cook ultimately admitted to all of the mystery hit and runs that had stumped investigators for years. In total, he had run down seven girls and young women between 1958 and 1960. Cook's newfound willingness to talk was at odds with his earlier reticence when admitting to his violent crimes. After one
生命。他能带警察去她家，并解释他所做的每一步以及她尸体被留下的样子。在与侦探们再次走访贝斯沃特街道时，库克承认他曾以其他方式伤害过女性。他指出了一个地点，在那里他开着一辆偷来的霍顿轿车撞倒了20岁的格莱尼斯·皮克。他对被盗车辆的描述、弃车地点以及车辆受损情况，都与案件事实相符。库克最终承认了所有多年来一直困扰调查人员的神秘肇事逃逸案。总共，他在1958年至1960年间撞倒了七名女孩和年轻女性。库克新表现出的交谈意愿，与他早先承认暴力罪行时的沉默寡言形成了鲜明对比。在一次
conversation that took place about a week and a half after his arrest, an investigator asked if there was anything else on his mind he felt like talking about. Yes, said Cook. I have committed two crimes for which two men are now serving a sentence of imprisonment. sponsors. At Algoma University, your future has no limits. Here, you can go further – in the classroom, in the field, and well beyond. We provide personalized education, cultural fluency, and training for in-demand careers. We don't just prepare you for the future. We prepare you to change it. Plus, Algoma has the most affordable tuition in Ontario.
发生在逮捕后约一周半的谈话中，一名调查人员问他还有什么想谈的。是的，库克说。我犯下了两起罪行，而现在有两名男子正在为此服刑。赞助商。在阿尔戈马大学，你的未来没有极限。在这里，你可以走得更远——在课堂上、在实践中，以及更广阔的天地。我们提供个性化的教育、文化素养和热门职业培训。我们不仅为你准备未来，我们还准备让你改变未来。此外，阿尔戈马拥有安大略省最实惠的学费。
Make the most of your university experience. Go further. Apply to Algoma University today. With the FIZ loyalty program, you get rewarded just for having a mobile plan. You know, for texting and stuff. And if you're not getting rewards like extra data and dollars off with your mobile plan, you're not with FIZ. Switch today. Conditions apply. You're not with Fizz. Switch today.
充分利用你的大学经历。走得更远。今天就申请阿尔戈马大学。通过FIZ忠诚度计划，你只需拥有一个移动套餐就能获得奖励。你知道的，就是发短信之类的。如果你的移动套餐没有获得额外数据和现金返还等奖励，那你用的就不是FIZ。今天就切换吧。条件适用。你用的不是Fizz。今天就切换吧。
Conditions apply. Details at fizz.ca. Thank you for listening to this episode's ads. By supporting our sponsors, you support Casefile to continue to deliver quality content. Exactly two weeks after the Australia Day shootings on Saturday, February 9, three young men who'd spent the day at a racehorse track drove home together around 10.30pm. Despite the fear that was gripping Perth, the young men had enjoyed their evening immensely, with the driver, 21-year-old Barry Hanson, winning several bets that he'd placed.
条件适用。详情请见fizz.ca。感谢您收听本集的广告。通过支持我们的赞助商，您支持Casefile继续提供优质内容。在澳大利亚日枪击案发生整整两周后的2月9日星期六，三名在赛马场度过一天的年轻人于晚上10点30分左右一起开车回家。尽管珀斯笼罩在恐惧之中，但这三名年轻人还是非常享受他们的夜晚，司机、21岁的巴里·汉森赢得了他下的几注赌注。
They were planning on having one final beer together when they reached one of their homes, but Barry noticed something as they headed along Stubbs Terrace in the western suburb of Shenton Park. Lying a few metres left of the road in some sand was what looked like a bundle of clothing. Slightly unnerved by the sight, Barry asked his two friends if they'd seen it. They hadn't. It looks like a body, Barry said. He decided to find a wider spot up ahead where he could safely make a U-turn and then drive back by the clothing to check everything was okay. About 60 metres up the road, they reached a hospital. Barry pulled into its driveway to turn around, then slowly drove back down Stubbs Terrace. When they reached the spot where Barry had seen the clothing, they saw there was now another car
当他们到达其中一人的家时，他们计划一起喝最后一杯啤酒，但巴里在沿着申顿公园西郊的斯塔布斯露台行驶时注意到了一些东西。在路左侧几米处的沙地上，躺着一个看起来像是一捆衣服的东西。巴里被这一幕弄得有些不安，问他的两个朋友是否看到了。他们没有。看起来像具尸体，巴里说。他决定在前方找一个更宽的地方，安全地掉头，然后开车回到衣服旁边检查一下是否一切正常。在前方约60米处，他们到达了一家医院。巴里驶入车道掉头，然后慢慢开回斯塔布斯露台。当他们到达巴里看到衣服的地方时，他们看到现在有另一辆车
pulled over. A 1962 Simca-Arand sedan with someone sitting behind the wheel. Barry kept driving further along, then made another U-turn and parked about 10 meters behind the other car, making sure to switch his headlights off. He and his friends sat there in the darkness, all feeling slightly nervous. The recent shootings were on their mind as they looked on, and Barry warned his friends not to get out of the car. What if the driver of this other car was the killer? The driver of the other car opened the door and ran towards the bundle of clothing alongside
停在路边。一辆1962年的西姆卡-阿兰德轿车，有人坐在驾驶座上。巴里继续向前行驶，然后再次掉头，停在另一辆车后约10米处，确保关掉了大灯。他和朋友们坐在黑暗中，都感到有些紧张。当他们注视着前方时，最近的枪击事件浮现在脑海中，巴里警告他的朋友们不要下车。如果这辆车的司机是杀手怎么办？另一辆车的司机打开车门，跑向路边那捆衣服。
the road. Barry's instincts had been right. The pile of clothing was, in fact, a young woman. The three men watched as the other driver picked up her limp body and struggled to carry it to his sim car. His actions were illuminated by his car's headlights and Barry noticed he was a young man who looked to be wearing shorts and no shirt. The man almost dropped the woman as he took her to his car and placed her in the front passenger seat. By this time another vehicle was
巴里的直觉是对的。那堆衣服实际上是一个年轻女子。三名男子看着另一名司机抱起她瘫软的身体，吃力地把它搬到他的西姆卡车上。他的动作被车头灯照亮，巴里注意到他是一个看起来穿着短裤、没穿上衣的年轻人。那名男子在把她带到车上并放在副驾驶座位时差点把她摔了。此时，另一辆车
passing by, its four occupants gazing out the windows at the strange scene as they drove past the shirtless man carrying the woman. They pulled over in front of his car, troubled by what they were seeing. The shirtless man paid no attention to the rubberneckers. Barry Hanson believed the shirtless man was the Australia Day shooter and was alarmed to see him place the body of either a deceased or unconscious woman in his car. Barry started his car and took off to raise the alarm. He'd driven about 300 or 400 metres when the Simca suddenly sped by him at 70 miles per hour. Barry decided to follow the Simca, which soon turned left and parked outside of a doctor's
经过，车上的四名乘客透过窗户看着这奇怪的一幕，从那个没穿上衣搬运女子的男人身边驶过。他们被所见的一幕困扰，停在了他的车前。那个没穿上衣的男人没有理会这些看热闹的人。巴里·汉森认为那个没穿上衣的男人就是澳大利亚日的枪手，看到他把一具已故或昏迷女子的尸体放进车里，感到非常震惊。巴里发动汽车，冲出去报警。他开了大约300或400米，那辆西姆卡突然以每小时70英里的速度从他身边飞驰而过。巴里决定跟随那辆西姆卡，它很快左转，停在了一家医生
office. Barry and his friends watched the shirtless man run to the doctor's front door. One of Barry's passengers, Wilson White, realised he recognised the man. His name was John Button and he was the boyfriend of Wilson's neighbour and former schoolmate, 17-year-old Rosemary Anderson. John returned and picked the young woman out of his car, carrying her inside to where the doctor was waiting. It was clear that the young woman was John's girlfriend, Rosemary. was John's girlfriend, Rosemary. John Barton had told the doctor, who was Rosemary's general practitioner, that she had a deep cut over her eye that was bleeding heavily.
诊所外。巴里和他的朋友们看着那个没穿上衣的男人跑向医生的前门。巴里的一名乘客威尔逊·怀特意识到他认出了这个人。他的名字叫约翰·巴顿，是威尔逊的邻居兼前校友、17岁的罗斯玛丽·安德森的男朋友。约翰回来，把那个年轻女子从车里抱出来，带进医生等待的地方。很明显，那个年轻女子是约翰的女朋友罗斯玛丽。约翰·巴顿告诉医生（他是罗斯玛丽的全科医生），她的眼睛上方有一道很深的伤口，流血不止。
Dr Joseph Quinlovin examined Rosemary and could tell that she had been struck by a vehicle. The cut on her forehead and the fact that her pupils weren't equal indicated a head injury. The doctor also believed she'd sustained damage to her chest. Rosemary was unconscious, her pulse was racing, and she was struggling to breathe. Her thighs, knees, and hips were covered with abrasions. Dr. Quinlovin noticed that John had blood smeared on his bare chest and his hands. There was also some blood on his trousers, which were rolled up to resemble shorts. After treating Rosemary as best as he could, the doctor called for an ambulance and the
约瑟夫·昆洛文医生检查了罗斯玛丽，看出她是被车辆撞伤的。她额头上的伤口以及瞳孔不等大表明有头部损伤。医生还认为她的胸部也受到了伤害。罗斯玛丽处于昏迷状态，脉搏急促，呼吸困难。她的大腿、膝盖和臀部布满了擦伤。昆洛文医生注意到约翰赤裸的胸部和手上沾满了血迹。他的裤子上也有一些血迹，裤腿卷起来看起来像短裤。在尽力救治罗斯玛丽后，医生叫了救护车和
police. Rosemary was transferred to Royal Perth Hospital arriving at 11.35pm. She was found to be deeply comatose and unresponsive to painful stimuli. Doctors worked on her for a couple of hours, but just as she was transferred to another ward, Rosemary suddenly stopped breathing. Efforts to resuscitate her failed, and at 2.30am she was pronounced dead. Meanwhile, John Barton was being questioned by two traffic officers. He told the police that that day was his 19th birthday and he'd spent the entire day with Rosemary celebrating.
警察。罗斯玛丽被转送到皇家珀斯医院，于晚上11点35分到达。她被发现处于深度昏迷状态，对疼痛刺激没有反应。医生们抢救了她几个小时，但就在她被转到另一个病房时，罗斯玛丽突然停止了呼吸。复苏努力失败，凌晨2点30分，她被宣布死亡。与此同时，约翰·巴顿正在接受两名交通警察的盘问。他告诉警察，那天是他19岁生日，他和罗斯玛丽整天都在庆祝。
John's parents were out that night, leaving him and his younger brother alone at their family residence in Subiaco and in a western suburb of Perth. Late into the evening, John and Rosemary had gone out to pick up fish and chips to share with the Johns brother. While they were eating the meal back at Johns house, Rosemary had reached for Johns piece of fish. John had loudly told her off, mistakenly thinking it was his brother taking the fish, not Rosemary. Hurt by his angry words, Rosemary had left to walk home alone at around 10.30pm. John got into his car and followed after his girlfriend. He repeatedly tried to talk to her, pulling up alongside her on the road as she walked, but Rosemary refused to speak to him.
约翰的父母那天晚上出去了，留他和弟弟独自在位于珀斯西郊苏比亚科的家中。深夜，约翰和罗斯玛丽出去买了炸鱼薯条，准备和约翰的弟弟分享。当他们在约翰家吃这顿饭时，罗斯玛丽伸手去拿约翰的那块鱼。约翰大声责骂了她，误以为是他的弟弟在拿鱼，而不是罗斯玛丽。被他愤怒的话语伤害，罗斯玛丽在晚上10点30分左右独自离开回家。约翰上了车，跟在女朋友后面。他多次试图和她说话，在她走路时把车停在路边，但罗斯玛丽拒绝和他说话。
John said he'd begged her to get in his car so he could drive her home to no avail. Finally, John stopped trying and parked his car, turning off the ignition and watching as Rosemary walked away and around the corner to Stubbs Terrace. After waiting several minutes and smoking a cigarette, he started the car up and decided to try again, heading left onto Stubbs Terrace as Rosemary had done. There, he found Rosemary lying unconscious by the road with a head wound. John believed she was the victim of a hit and run and had quickly decided to take her to her doctor to get help.
约翰说他曾恳求她上车，让他送她回家，但无济于事。最后，约翰放弃了尝试，停下车，熄火，看着罗斯玛丽走开，转过拐角进入斯塔布斯露台。等待了几分钟并抽了一支烟后，他发动汽车决定再试一次，像罗斯玛丽一样左转进入斯塔布斯露台。在那里，他发现罗斯玛丽昏迷不醒地躺在路边，头部有伤。约翰认为她是肇事逃逸的受害者，并迅速决定带她去看医生寻求帮助。
The police noted there was significant damage to the front left side of John's car and it was dotted with spots of blood. In the back seat was a girdle and a pair of stockings. When asked what had happened to his car, John claimed he'd been in an accident with another car a few weeks earlier. He said that Rosemary always took off her stockings when she rode in his car because she didn't want to get ladders in them. But he stammered as he gave his explanation and seemed nervous. John was interrogated for six hours and provided a lengthy, detailed statement maintaining his version of events. Detectives didn't believe him. They thought a fight over fish and chips sounded ridiculous and suspected something else had caused the young couple to argue that night. They believed John and Rosemary had likely been fooling around in the back of his car,
警方注意到约翰汽车的左前方有明显的损坏，并点缀着血迹。后座上有一条束腰带和一双长筒袜。当被问及他的车发生了什么事时，约翰声称他几周前与另一辆车发生了事故。他说罗斯玛丽坐他的车时总是脱掉长筒袜，因为她不想把袜子勾破。但他解释时结结巴巴，显得很紧张。约翰被审讯了六个小时，并提供了一份冗长、详细的陈述，坚持他的版本。侦探们不相信他。他们认为因为炸鱼薯条吵架听起来很荒谬，怀疑还有其他原因导致这对年轻情侣那天晚上争吵。他们认为约翰和罗斯玛丽很可能在车后座亲热，
hence why her undergarments were on the back seat. Perhaps Rosemary had wanted to stop and that was why she'd gotten out and left on foot. Angered, John had followed his girlfriend and ran her down in a rage. Maybe he hadn't intended to hit her, maybe he'd just planned to scare her but got too close by mistake. Ultimately though, she had been hit and John then panicked about his actions. Detectives continued to interrogate John and started getting physical with him as their frustration grew. They punched the 19-year-old several times. But all John could focus on was Rosemary, so he asked if they knew how she was doing. Oh, she's dead, the detectives informed him. Rosemary had passed away a couple of hours earlier at the hospital.
所以她的内衣才会在后座上。也许罗斯玛丽想停下来，这就是她下车步行离开的原因。愤怒之下，约翰跟在女朋友后面，在狂怒中撞倒了她。也许他没打算撞她，也许他只是想吓唬她，但错误地靠得太近了。然而，最终她还是被撞了，约翰随后对自己的行为感到恐慌。侦探们继续审讯约翰，随着挫败感的增加，他们开始对他动粗。他们多次殴打这名19岁的年轻人。但约翰关心的只有罗斯玛丽，所以他问他们是否知道她怎么样了。哦，她死了，侦探们告诉他。罗斯玛丽几个小时前在医院去世了。
John became sick after learning this and went to the bathroom to throw up. What have I done? It was all my fault, John said. Do you mean she was struck by your car? the detectives pressed. No longer caring what happened to him, John replied, yes. He then provided a new statement, this time confessing that he was the one who hit Rosemary. John abandoned the story about the fish and chips, instead saying they'd argued after playing strip poker. Rosemary had removed her stockings and girdle as part of the game and then John had tried to fondle Rosemary's breasts. This caused her to storm out. John had grabbed her undergarments and tossed them into his car before driving after her. After repeatedly trying to speak with her while she walked home,
约翰得知这个消息后感到恶心，去洗手间呕吐。我做了什么？这都是我的错，约翰说。你是说她是被你的车撞的吗？侦探们追问。不再关心自己会发生什么，约翰回答说，是的。他随后提供了一份新的陈述，这次承认是他撞了罗斯玛丽。约翰放弃了关于炸鱼薯条的故事，转而说他们在玩脱衣扑克后发生了争吵。罗斯玛丽作为游戏的一部分脱掉了长筒袜和束腰带，然后约翰试图抚摸罗斯玛丽的胸部。这导致她冲了出去。约翰抓起她的内衣扔进车里，然后开车追她。在多次试图在她走路回家时与她交谈后，
he'd decided to scare her by pretending he was going to hit her. As Rosemary walked on the left side of Stubbs Terrace, John drove towards her at 35mph, or just over 56kmh. Before he could realise what had happened, the left side of his car struck Rosemary with a loud crunch. John would later renege his confession, explaining that he'd been through intense questioning and in his extreme grief he'd felt responsible, as it was his mistake of shouting at Rosemary that led to her refusing a lift from him. He was compelled to tell a story that sounded more believable to the police. The reason Rosemary's undergarments had been in his car was because they'd had sex there earlier that evening. John hadn't wanted to tell anyone that as he wanted to protect Rosemary's reputation.
他决定通过假装要撞她来吓唬她。当罗斯玛丽走在斯塔布斯露台的左侧时，约翰以每小时35英里（即每小时56公里多一点）的速度向她开去。在他意识到发生了什么之前，他车的左侧以一声巨响撞上了罗斯玛丽。约翰后来撤回了他的供词，解释说他经历了高强度的审讯，在极度悲痛中他感到自己有责任，因为是他对罗斯玛丽大喊大叫的错误导致她拒绝了他的搭车。他被迫编造了一个听起来对警察更可信的故事。罗斯玛丽的内衣之所以在他的车里，是因为他们那天晚上早些时候在车里发生了性关系。约翰不想告诉任何人，因为他想保护罗斯玛丽的名声。
He had adored Rosemary and the two had been planning to get married. Despite all of this, John Barton was tried less than three months later and convicted of manslaughter. He was sentenced to 10 years with hard labour. sentenced to 10 years with hard labour. Months after John was convicted, confessed spree killer Eric Edgar Cook told investigators that he was in fact responsible for the murder of Rosemary Anderson. Cook said that at around 8.30 on the night of Saturday February 9, he had stolen a brand new two-tone green Holden from a home in South Perth. He drove to the city, then west, through the affluent suburbs he particularly liked to prey on. At around 10pm, he was heading along Stubbs Terrace in Shenton Park when he noticed Rosemary Anderson walking alone on the side of the road.
他深爱着罗斯玛丽，两人原本计划结婚。尽管如此，约翰·巴顿还是在不到三个月后受审，并被判过失杀人罪。他被判处10年苦役。在约翰被定罪几个月后，连环杀手埃里克·埃德加·库克告诉调查人员，他实际上应对罗斯玛丽·安德森的谋杀案负责。库克说，在2月9日星期六晚上8点30分左右，他从南珀斯的一户人家偷了一辆全新的双色绿色霍顿车。他开车进城，然后向西，穿过他特别喜欢猎食的富裕郊区。晚上10点左右，他沿着申顿公园的斯塔布斯露台行驶时，注意到罗斯玛丽·安德森独自走在路边。
All night, Cook had been feeling a desire to hurt someone rise inside him, and he decided Rosemary would be his victim. He continued driving past the teenager, then did a U-turn and drove straight at her at 40 miles per hour, or just under 65 kilometres per hour. Rosemary didn't make a sound as the front right-hand side of the car struck her. She was thrown onto the bonnet, struck the sun visor that jutted out over the Holden's windscreen, then rolled off onto the side of the road. Cook continued driving, turning right down a side street then left before parking. He got out to survey the damage. There was an obvious dent on the bonnet and a few spots of blood which he wiped away with a handkerchief. After about five minutes,
整晚，库克内心都感到一种伤害他人的欲望在升腾，他决定罗斯玛丽将成为他的受害者。他继续开车经过这名少女，然后掉头，以每小时40英里（即每小时不到65公里）的速度径直向她开去。当车右前方撞上她时，罗斯玛丽没有发出任何声音。她被抛到引擎盖上，撞上了霍顿挡风玻璃上方突出的遮阳板，然后滚落到路边。库克继续开车，右转进入一条小路，然后左转停车。他下车查看损坏情况。引擎盖上有明显的凹痕和几处血迹，他用手帕擦掉了。大约五分钟后，
Cook got back in the car and drove back to the crime scene. He passed a couple of cars headed in the other direction on the way. When he reached the spot where he'd hit Rosemary, he saw no sign of her. Cook figured somebody must have found the girl and taken her to the hospital. figured somebody must have found the girl and taken her to the hospital. He kept driving east, heading towards a large public garden known as Kings Park. Cook turned left onto a roadway called May Drive and abandoned the vehicle. The entire drive was lined with memorial trees in honour of fallen Australian soldiers, and Cook decided to drive into one. He reduced his speed to 20 miles per hour, or 32 kilometres per hour, and drove directly at a tree,
库克回到车里，开车回到犯罪现场。途中他经过了几辆朝相反方向行驶的汽车。当他到达撞到罗斯玛丽的地方时，他没有看到她的踪影。库克认为一定有人发现了这个女孩并把她送到了医院。他继续向东行驶，前往一个被称为国王公园的大型公共花园。库克左转进入一条名为梅大道的道路，弃车而去。整条大道两旁种满了纪念阵亡澳大利亚士兵的纪念树，库克决定开车撞向其中一棵。他将速度降至每小时20英里（即每小时32公里），直接撞向一棵树，
further damaging the car. Cook got out, walked for a distance, then caught a taxi home. After he took detectives through a step-by-step process of the night in question, he completed a handwritten confession about the crime. He concluded it with the words, "...my reason for running down the girl was just to inflict injury and pain on her. I never knew her. The reason I left this statement until I were arrested on other matters was, first, when it happened I didn't want to be charged with this crime. Second, now that I have been arrested on other matters and have so much more against me, this bit can't hurt me, and I'd like to see an innocent person like John Button free."
进一步损坏了汽车。库克下车，走了一段路，然后打车回家。在带领侦探们一步步重现了那个晚上的过程后，他完成了一份关于该罪行的手写供词。他在结尾写道：“……我撞倒那个女孩的原因只是为了给她造成伤害和痛苦。我不认识她。我之所以把这份陈述留到因其他事项被捕后才说，第一，事情发生时我不想被指控犯有此罪。第二，既然我现在因其他事项被捕，身上背负了更多罪名，这一点也无所谓了，而且我想看到像约翰·巴顿这样的无辜者获得自由。”
Even though this random attack against Rosemary Anderson would be in keeping with Cook's previous hit and runs, detectives weren't buying his confession. When Cook had pointed to the spot on the ground where Rosemary's body had lain, he was out by a few metres. Then, when they took Cook to May Drive and asked him to point out the tree he'd driven into, he was unable to. He chose a tree that was actually several trees away from the location where the Holden had been found. After the car was discovered smashed into the tree back in February, it had been returned to its rightful owner. Following Cook's new claims, investigators went to inspect the vehicle but found none
尽管这次对罗斯玛丽·安德森的随机袭击符合库克之前的肇事逃逸作案手法，但侦探们并不相信他的供词。当库克指着地上罗斯玛丽尸体躺过的地方时，他偏差了几米。然后，当他们带库克去梅大道并要求他指出他撞上的那棵树时，他没能做到。他选了一棵树，实际上距离发现霍顿车的地方有好几棵树之遥。在那辆车于2月被发现撞在树上后，它已被归还给合法车主。在库克提出新的说法后，调查人员去检查了车辆，但没有发现他描述的
of the damage to the bonnet that he'd described, although it had been repaired after its recovery. Detectives also found some of Cook's other details to bear at odds with the actual events. Rosemary had been hit at around 10.45pm, not 10pm. Some items belonging to her were found some distance from where Cook said that he'd struck her, and his descriptions of where he'd been when he spotted Rosemary then drove towards her did not align with where Rosemary was found. As one investigator told him, considering the pace you say you were travelling and the distance you say you covered from the time when you first saw her to where you say you hit her, it appears impossible that these circumstances could have
引擎盖上的任何损坏，尽管它在找回后已经修理过了。侦探们还发现库克的其他一些细节与实际事件不符。罗斯玛丽是在晚上10点45分左右被撞的，而不是10点。她的一些物品在距离库克所说撞击地点很远的地方被发现，而且他对自己发现罗斯玛丽然后开车冲向她时所在位置的描述，与罗斯玛丽被发现的地方不一致。正如一名调查人员告诉他的那样：“考虑到你所说的行驶速度，以及从你第一次看到她到你所说撞到她所经过的距离，这些情况似乎是不可能发生的。”
occurred." Cook became confused, stating, "...I don't understand it. I am sure I killed her." Not long after he had written his confession, Cook penned a retraction in which he put his vivid recollection of killing Rosemary Anderson down to an overactive imagination. Quote, "...by reading all the available papers on this crime and remembering where it took place and the person involved, I were able to describe what I believe I did. Having read some books, I get so engrossed in them that I project myself and believe I'm the person in those books. Having given further thought to my admissions to the detectives, I'm now of the opinion that I couldn't have been the person associated with the death of Rosemary Anderson.
库克变得困惑，说：“……我不明白。我确信我杀了她。”在他写下供词后不久，库克写了一份撤回声明，将他对自己杀害罗斯玛丽·安德森的生动回忆归咎于过度活跃的想象力。引用：“……通过阅读所有关于此案的现有报纸，并记住它发生的地方和涉及的人，我能够描述出我相信我所做的事情。读了一些书后，我太沉迷其中，以至于我将自己投射进去，并相信我就是书中的那个人。在进一步思考我对侦探们的供述后，我现在认为我不可能是与罗斯玛丽·安德森之死有关的那个人。”
As Cook's certainty about this confession waned, so too did his belief in another admission that he'd made. The vicious and violent murder of 22-year-old socialite and heiress, Gillian Brewer, on Saturday December 19 1959 had sent shockwaves through Perth. The young woman had been struck with a hatchet and stabbed with scissors while asleep in her bed, with Perth's coroner calling it the worst murder he had ever seen. Investigators hadn't linked it to the spate of break-ins or other murders of women. After a 19-year-old deaf, non-verbal man named Darryl Beamish came to the police's attention for other offences in 1961, detectives began to suspect him of Gillian's murder.
随着库克对这份供词的确定性减弱，他对另一项供词的信念也随之减弱。1959年12月19日星期六，22岁的名媛兼女继承人吉莉安·布鲁尔惨遭杀害，这在珀斯引起了轰动。这名年轻女子在床上睡觉时被斧头击中并被剪刀刺伤，珀斯的验尸官称这是他见过的最严重的谋杀案。调查人员没有将其与一系列入室盗窃案或其他女性谋杀案联系起来。1961年，一名19岁的聋哑男子达里尔·比米什因其他罪行引起警方注意后，侦探们开始怀疑他是吉莉安谋杀案的凶手。
Darryl had a difficult life in which he faced discrimination and social exclusion due to his disabilities. He was described as having the verbal understanding of a seven-year-old and communicated via signing and using his fingers to spell out words. Darryl was close with his family, who knew him to be gentle and kind, but struggled to make friends with other members of the community. In turn, he didn't always act appropriately, with some reports that he would rush up to girls at a local cinema in an attempt to get close to them. Darrell later befriended a young woman named Dan who lived at Brookwood Flats, the same Codderslow apartment complex where Gillian Brewer had lived.
达里尔的生活很艰难，由于残疾，他面临着歧视和社会排斥。据描述，他的语言理解能力相当于一个七岁的孩子，通过手语和用手指拼写单词进行交流。达里尔与家人关系密切，家人知道他温柔善良，但他很难与社区的其他成员交朋友。反过来，他的行为并不总是得体，有报道称他会冲向当地电影院的女孩，试图接近她们。达里尔后来结识了一位名叫安的年轻女子，她住在布鲁克伍德公寓，也就是吉莉安·布鲁尔居住的科特斯洛公寓大楼。
Cottesloe apartment complex where Gillian Brewer had lived. Anne later moved away around January 1961. As Darryl couldn't telephone her due to his disabilities, he began hanging around the flats in search of someone who might know where he could find her. At the same time, a prowler around the area had been breaking into apartments. This would lead police officers to believe Darrell and the prowler were one and the same. In April 1961, Darrell was charged with a very serious crime. In four separate incidents, little girls aged between four and five years old accused him of coaxing them into his car, driving them to King's Park, and then parking the car. He would then lift up their dresses, pull down their underwear, and look at them before driving them back to the
科特斯洛公寓大楼。安后来在1961年1月左右搬走了。由于残疾，达里尔无法给她打电话，于是开始在公寓附近徘徊，寻找可能知道他在哪里能找到她的人。与此同时，该地区的一名潜行者一直在闯入公寓。这导致警官们认为达里尔和潜行者是同一个人。1961年4月，达里尔被指控犯有非常严重的罪行。在四起独立的事件中，四到五岁的小女孩指控他诱骗她们上车，开车把她们带到国王公园，然后停车。他会掀起她们的裙子，拉下她们的内衣，看着她们，然后把她们送回他找到她们的地方。
location where he'd found them. Darryl admitted to these assaults and would later plead guilty to them in court. His status as a sex offender and association with the Brookwood Flats led investigators to wonder if he could be Gilliam Brewer's killer. He initially denied having anything to do with the murder, but eventually admitted to it after hours of intimidation and threats. His written confession was made by copying down the written answers that the detectives provided. In total, the statement was four pages long with very scant detail about the actual crime. Another confession was also made via a sign language interpreter who repeatedly ignored Darryl when he told her he was innocent. He was ultimately convicted of
达里尔承认了这些袭击，并后来在法庭上认罪。他作为性犯罪者的身份以及与布鲁克伍德公寓的联系，使调查人员怀疑他是否可能是吉莉安·布鲁尔的凶手。他最初否认与谋杀案有任何关系，但在数小时的恐吓和威胁后最终承认了。他的书面供词是通过抄写侦探提供的书面答案而写成的。总的来说，这份陈述有四页长，关于实际犯罪的细节非常少。另一份供词也是通过一名手语翻译做出的，她多次无视达里尔告诉她他是无辜的。他最终被判
murder and given the death sentence. The matter was considered solved until Eric Edgar Cook threw a spanner in the works two and a half years later by confessing to the crime. Just as he'd done with all the other crimes, he gave a detailed description of how he had killed Gillian Brewer and his actions on that night. Cook had actually already been questioned about the crime one month after it was committed due to his known history as a prowler. He'd said he was home at the time, and alibi his wife backed up. Years later, Sally Cook explained that the day
谋杀罪并被判处死刑。这件事被认为已经解决，直到两年半后埃里克·埃德加·库克通过承认罪行打破了局面。就像他对待所有其他罪行一样，他详细描述了他是如何杀害吉莉安·布鲁尔的，以及他那天晚上的行为。库克实际上在犯罪发生一个月后就因其作为潜行者的已知历史而被问及此案。他说他当时在家，他的妻子也提供了不在场证明。多年后，萨莉·库克解释说，在吉莉安谋杀案发生的
after Gillian's murder, Cook had shown her an article about the crime in the paper. The two had discussed how warful it was, and then Cook had asked his wife to tell the police he was at home that night if they asked any questions. He explained that due to his prior convictions for prowling they would try to pin it on him. Sally Cook accepted this and did as her husband asked. Cook's confession to the murder of Gillian Brewer amounted to 14 pages when transcribed. He said that he had been to Gillian's apartment building before and had robbed her mother. On the night of Saturday December 19 1959, he went there again and watched Gillian with her her fiance through her bedroom window.
第二天，库克给她看了报纸上关于这起罪行的一篇文章。两人讨论了这件事有多可怕，然后库克要求他的妻子如果警察问起，就告诉他们他那天晚上在家。他解释说，由于他之前有潜行前科，他们会试图把罪名扣在他头上。萨莉·库克接受了这一点，并按照丈夫的要求做了。库克对吉莉安·布鲁尔谋杀案的供词在转录后长达14页。他说他以前去过吉莉安的公寓楼，并抢劫过她的母亲。1959年12月19日星期六晚上，他再次去了那里，透过卧室窗户看着吉莉安和她的未婚夫。
He heard the two chatting and saw when Jillian's fiance left. Cook went around the back of the apartment and entered via the rear door, which was unlocked. As he pushed the door open, he heard a scraping sound on the cement floor. Shining his torch down, he saw a small bottle of milk that had just been delivered to the home, placing his time of entry at 1am. Cook used the bottle to keep the door propped open, then went to Jillian's bedroom where he attacked her with a hatchet he'd stolen from a nearby property. The sound of the assault woke Jillian's pet poodle who hid under the bed in fear while barking at the intruder. Cook was able to soothe the dog by patting him and making a gentle shushing sound. A neighbour had verified hearing Jillian's dog briefly bark at this time. But once again,
他听到两人在聊天，并看到了吉莉安的未婚夫离开的时间。库克绕到公寓后面，从没锁的后门进入。当他推开门时，他听到水泥地板上有刮擦声。他用手电筒照下去，看到一瓶刚送到家里的牛奶，确定他进入的时间是凌晨1点。库克用瓶子把门撑开，然后去了吉莉安的卧室，用他从附近一处房产偷来的斧头袭击了她。袭击的声音吵醒了吉莉安的宠物贵宾犬，它躲在床下害怕地对着入侵者吠叫。库克通过拍打它并发出轻柔的嘘声安抚了这只狗。一位邻居证实当时听到了吉莉安的狗短暂地吠叫。但再一次，
police were able to convince Cook that he could not have committed this crime, and he agreed to retract this admission as well. Three weeks after his initial arrest, Cook was transferred to prison to await his trial. He was assigned two defence lawyers through Western Australia's Legal Aid program. He provided more candid confessions to his attorneys, even going so far as to confess to killing Rosemary Anderson and Gilliam Brewer again. Police would keep many of these confessions secret from the public, including the seven hit and runs against women and the assaults of women in their own homes. Eric Edgar Cook's trial
警方能够说服库克他不可能犯下这起罪行，他也同意撤回这一供词。在最初被捕三周后，库克被转移到监狱等待审判。他通过西澳大利亚州的法律援助计划被指派了两名辩护律师。他向律师提供了更坦率的供词，甚至进一步承认再次杀害了罗斯玛丽·安德森和吉莉安·布鲁尔。警方将许多这些供词对公众保密，包括针对女性的七起肇事逃逸案以及在受害者家中对女性的袭击。埃里克·埃德加·库克的审判
began in November 1963, less than three months after his arrest. The first charge he was facing was for the murder of John Sturkey during the Australia Day shootings. Because Cook openly admitted to killing his victims, his lawyers were arguing that he was not guilty by reason of insanity. After reviewing Cook's background and speaking extensively with his family, they believed he was suffering from a mental illness, most likely schizophrenia. Cook's mother told the attorneys about her son's history of headaches and blackouts. The defence wanted to have a private psychiatrist examine Cook and provide an assessment of his mental state, but this was denied by the court.
开始于1963年11月，距离他被捕不到三个月。他面临的第一项指控是澳大利亚日枪击案中约翰·斯特基的谋杀案。因为库克公开承认杀害了他的受害者，他的律师辩称他因精神错乱而无罪。在审查了库克的背景并与他的家人进行了广泛交谈后，他们认为他患有精神疾病，很可能是精神分裂症。库克的母亲告诉律师她儿子头痛和昏厥的历史。辩方希望让一名私人精神科医生检查库克并对其精神状态进行评估，但这被法院拒绝了。
Instead, he was assessed by a senior mental health practitioner employed by the state, but this was denied by the court. Instead, he was assessed by a senior mental health practitioner employed by the state, Dr Aranelis. Dr Aranelis found no indication that Cook was suffering from delusions, a symptom of schizophrenia, nor that he lacked the ability to control his actions. that he lacked the ability to control his actions. In fact, Dr Ellis pointed to the lengths Cook had gone to in order to conceal his responsibility, such as wearing gloves and discarding weapons. These were not the actions of someone who wasn't in control. Cook had also been able to maintain the facade of being a good husband and father and worked hard to provide for his family. His total lack of remorse for his crimes was concerning but not an indication of insanity. Instead, it was more likely the consequence of a, quote,
相反，他由州政府聘用的一名高级心理健康从业者阿兰尼斯医生进行了评估，但这被法院拒绝了。相反，他由州政府聘用的一名高级心理健康从业者阿兰尼斯医生进行了评估。阿兰尼斯医生没有发现库克患有妄想症（精神分裂症的一种症状）的迹象，也没有发现他缺乏控制自己行为的能力。事实上，埃利斯医生指出了库克为掩盖自己的责任所做的努力，例如戴手套和丢弃武器。这些不是一个无法控制自己的人的行为。库克还能够维持一个好丈夫和好父亲的形象，并努力工作以供养他的家人。他对自己的罪行完全没有悔意，这令人担忧，但并不是精神错乱的迹象。相反，这更有可能是某种“心理变态人格障碍”，例如反社会人格障碍的结果。
psychopathic character disorder, such as antisocial personality disorder. Dr Ellis believed Cook's criminal behaviour was the result of a long-simmering resentment towards society at large. In superficial encounters, he presented as polite, compliant, and passive. Beneath that surface image was a self-obsessed man who wanted to vent his rage against those who he perceived as rejecting or wronging him. He often chose victims from well-off areas because they represented the people he believed had rejected him. Cook himself had always lived in working class suburbs. Quote, I think this man's antisocial reactions can be traced back to his early childhood and his resentment at having been born with a hair lip and cleft palate. The children at school picked on him
埃利斯医生认为库克的犯罪行为是长期以来对整个社会积怨的结果。在表面的接触中，他表现得礼貌、顺从且被动。在那层形象之下，是一个自我沉迷的男人，他想向那些他认为拒绝或冤枉他的人发泄愤怒。他经常从富裕地区选择受害者，因为他们代表了他认为拒绝他的人。库克本人一直住在工人阶级郊区。引用：“我认为这个人的反社会反应可以追溯到他的童年早期，以及他因天生兔唇和腭裂而产生的怨恨。学校里的孩子们欺负他，
and he regarded himself as the freak of the family. His persistent stealing, arson, and finally murders all seemed directed towards satisfying his craving for power over others. Cook harboured particular resentment towards women who made up the majority of his victims. He was both traumatised by his father's violence towards his mother and angry at the women he perceived as rejecting him socially and romantically. His wife Sally would later tell Perth Journalist Brett Christian, Eric wasn't really insane. He had a grudge against society. He saw his mother beaten up. He didn't know how to relate to women. The trial lasted just three days and it only took the jury of eight men and
他把自己视为家里的怪胎。他持续的偷窃、纵火，以及最后的谋杀，似乎都是为了满足他对权力的渴望。库克对女性怀有特别的怨恨，她们构成了他受害者的大多数。他既被父亲对母亲的暴力所创伤，又对那些他认为在社交和浪漫上拒绝他的女性感到愤怒。他的妻子萨莉后来告诉珀斯记者布雷特·克里斯蒂安，埃里克并不是真的疯了。他对社会有怨恨。他看到母亲被殴打。他不知道如何与女性相处。审判仅持续了三天，八名男陪审员只用了
four women one hour and five minutes to reach a verdict. Guilty. Eric Edgar Cook would be sentenced to death by hanging for the murder of John Sturkey. This sentence meant that the prosecution would not be pursuing the other murder and criminal charges against Cook. Cook ordered his attorneys not to file an appeal, even though they were still concerned about his mental state. His hanging was set to be carried out at 8am on Monday October 26 1964, one year and two months after his arrest. 15 minutes before Cook was executed, he took a Bible from the hand of a reverend who was visiting him, and while holding it, he stated, I swear before Almighty God that I killed Anderson and Brewer. Eric Edgar Cooke was the last person to be executed in the state of Western Australia.
四名女性，一小时五分钟，陪审团达成裁决。有罪。埃里克·埃德加·库克因谋杀约翰·斯特基被判处绞刑。这一判决意味着检方将不再追究库克其他谋杀和刑事指控。库克命令他的律师不要上诉，尽管他们仍然担心他的精神状态。他的绞刑定于1964年10月26日星期一上午8点执行，距离他被捕已过去一年零两个月。在库克被处决前15分钟，他从一位探望他的牧师手中接过一本圣经，并握着它宣称：“我在全能的上帝面前发誓，是我杀了安德森和布鲁尔。”埃里克·埃德加·库克是西澳大利亚州最后一名被处决的人。
The death penalty was later abolished in 1984. Cook had repeatedly confessed to the murders of Rosemary Anderson and Gillian Brewer during his incarceration. He'd written statements detailing those crimes and signed affidavits. But neither the police nor the judiciary believed him, instead thinking he was just trying to delay his sentence. However, the truth was there were multiple issues and inconsistencies with their cases against the two men who had been convicted of those crimes. John Button tried to appeal his manslaughter conviction, citing Cook's confession as new evidence. His appeals failed and he served five years of his 10-year sentence before being
死刑后来于1984年被废除。库克在服刑期间曾多次承认谋杀罗斯玛丽·安德森和吉莉安·布鲁尔。他写下了详细描述这些罪行的陈述并签署了宣誓书。但警方和司法部门都不相信他，反而认为他只是想拖延刑期。然而，事实是，针对那两名被判犯有这些罪行的人的案件存在多个问题和不一致之处。约翰·巴顿试图对他的过失杀人罪判决提出上诉，并引用库克的供词作为新证据。他的上诉失败了，他在10年刑期中服刑了五年，之后被
paroled. He struggled to put the pieces of his life back together, grappling with grief and an intense guilt for not being able to prevent Rosemary's murder. The young couple had been planning to get married when Rosemary turned 18. Instead, John had to mourn Rosemary and also take the blame after her life suddenly ended in a violent and shocking way. Rosemary's parents and many of John's friends cut him off, believing he was guilty. He was still desperate for his name to be cleared, so he wrote to everyone he could think of who might be able to help. John did this for three decades with no success. He eventually married and had two children, but still felt stuck, haunted by grief and injustice.
假释。他努力拼凑自己破碎的生活，在悲痛和强烈的内疚感中挣扎，因为他没能阻止罗斯玛丽的谋杀。这对年轻夫妇原本计划在罗斯玛丽满18岁时结婚。然而，约翰却不得不哀悼罗斯玛丽，并在她以暴力和令人震惊的方式突然离世后承担了指责。罗斯玛丽的父母和约翰的许多朋友都与他断绝了关系，认为他有罪。他仍然渴望洗清自己的名声，所以他写信给所有他能想到可能提供帮助的人。约翰坚持了三十年，但毫无结果。他最终结婚并有了两个孩子，但仍然感到被困住，被悲伤和不公正所困扰。
John sunk into a deep depression. He attempted suicide multiple times and had to be admitted for psychiatric treatment. The aftershocks of Cook's crime would continue to be felt by John Button's wife and two children, who also suffered the consequences of John's trauma. John's story eventually caught the attention of Perth the journalist Estelle Blackburn. She had been in her early teens when the nightcaller stalked the city and had experienced the same fear as other residents after the Australia Day shootings. She was so terrified that she refused to use the outhouse at her family home after dark in case the shooter was lurking nearby.
约翰陷入了深深的抑郁。他多次尝试自杀，不得不入院接受精神治疗。库克罪行的余波继续影响着约翰·巴顿的妻子和两个孩子，他们也承受了约翰创伤的后果。约翰的故事最终引起了珀斯记者埃斯特尔·布莱克本的注意。当“夜间来电者”在城市中潜行时，她还是个十几岁的少女，在澳大利亚日枪击事件后，她经历了和其他居民一样的恐惧。她非常害怕，以至于天黑后不敢使用家里的户外厕所，生怕枪手潜伏在附近。
Three decades later in 1991, Estelle was at a dance where she had a chance encounter with the John Buttons brother Jim, who told her that his brother had been wrongfully convicted for a crime actually committed by Eric Edgar Cook. Estelle didn't believe Jim at first, she had a strong faith in the police and the justice system, but she began digging into the case out of curiosity. Estelle met with John and was intrigued by his story. Through her contacts, she was able to access all of the police files about the Cook and Barton cases, which had been archived decades earlier and never made public. While trawling through the files, Estelle stumbled across confession after confession made by Eric Edgar Cooke,
三十年后的1991年，埃斯特尔在一次舞会上偶然遇到了约翰·巴顿的兄弟吉姆，吉姆告诉她，他的兄弟因埃里克·埃德加·库克实际犯下的罪行而被错误定罪。起初，埃斯特尔并不相信吉姆，她对警察和司法系统有着坚定的信念，但出于好奇，她开始深入调查此案。埃斯特尔会见了约翰，并对他的故事产生了浓厚兴趣。通过她的人脉，她得以查阅所有关于库克和巴顿案件的警方档案，这些档案几十年前就被归档，从未公开。在翻阅档案时，埃斯特尔偶然发现了埃里克·埃德加·库克的一份又一份供词，
admitting to countless violent crimes across Perth. Through these statements, Estelle Blackburn was able to track down other victims and hear their stories firsthand. She spoke to the seven women who'd survived Cooke's hit and runs. All of the stories matched up. Estelle believed their stories were deliberately withheld from the public as they would make the case against John Button far weaker and police did not want to undermine his conviction. She continued digging over the next six years and her efforts uncovered a brand new witness who had never been interviewed before – a man who had been out riding his Vespa scooter with his girlfriend on the night Rosemary Anderson was killed.
承认在珀斯犯下了无数暴力罪行。通过这些陈述，埃斯特尔·布莱克本得以追踪到其他受害者并亲耳听取她们的故事。她采访了七名在库克的肇事逃逸中幸存下来的女性。所有的故事都吻合。埃斯特尔认为，她们的故事被故意向公众隐瞒，因为这会使针对约翰·巴顿的案件变得非常薄弱，而警方不想破坏对他的定罪。在接下来的六年里，她继续挖掘，她的努力发现了一位从未被采访过的新证人——一个在罗斯玛丽·安德森被杀当晚骑着Vespa摩托车带着女友外出的男人。
Doug Wilkie had been riding along Stubbs Terrace, the street where Rosemary was run down, when a light-coloured Holden sped up behind them. Doug also sped up to put some space between them, but the Holden pursued, its engine revving. Doug knew the driver wanted to run them down. Suddenly, another car appeared ahead of them. This new witness prompted the Holden driver to slow down and Doug was able to get away. This story seemed to back up Cook's claim that he was in the area looking for victims. Estelle Blackburn wound up writing a book about the case titled Broken Lives. It was published in 1998 by Brett Christian, who owned the Perth community publication Post Newspapers. Broken Lives led to renewed interest in the old case, and soon lawyers were offering to represent
道格·威尔基当时正沿着罗斯玛丽被撞的街道——斯塔布斯露台骑行，这时一辆浅色的霍顿汽车在他们身后加速。道格也加速以拉开距离，但霍顿汽车紧追不舍，引擎轰鸣。道格知道司机想撞倒他们。突然，前方出现了另一辆车。这位新证人促使霍顿司机减速，道格得以逃脱。这个故事似乎支持了库克关于他在该地区寻找受害者的说法。埃斯特尔·布莱克本最终写了一本关于此案的书，名为《破碎的生活》（Broken Lives）。该书于1998年由拥有珀斯社区出版物《邮报》（Post Newspapers）的布雷特·克里斯蒂安出版。《破碎的生活》引起了人们对旧案的重新关注，很快就有律师主动提出为
John Button pro bono. An American crash test expert was brought in and conducted a series of tests using a dummy and the same models of Holden and Simca that Cook and John had been driving, respectively. Via these tests, the expert was able to determine that the damage to John's car was inconsistent with having hit a pedestrian as it was too low down on the bumper. There was no dent on the bonnet where Rosemary would have fallen. Meanwhile, Cook's description of how Rosemary's body was struck and fell when hit by the holding he was driving was entirely accurate. Eventually, four years after the publication of Broken Lives, John Button's conviction was quashed in 2002. The following year, he was awarded $460,000 by the state as compensation. John Barton's exoneration paved the way for Darrell Beamish to file his own appeal.
约翰·巴顿提供无偿法律援助。一位美国碰撞测试专家被请来，使用假人和库克与约翰当时驾驶的同款霍顿和西姆卡汽车进行了一系列测试。通过这些测试，专家确定约翰车上的损坏与撞击行人不符，因为损坏位置在保险杠上太低了。引擎盖上没有罗斯玛丽跌落时应有的凹痕。与此同时，库克对罗斯玛丽的身体是如何被撞击并跌落的描述完全准确。最终，在《破碎的生活》出版四年后，约翰·巴顿的定罪于2002年被撤销。次年，他获得了州政府46万澳元的赔偿。约翰·巴顿的平反为达里尔·比米什提出自己的上诉铺平了道路。
He had originally been sentenced to death for killing Gillian Brewer. However, this sentence was subsequently reduced to life in prison and Beamish was ultimately released after 15 years. While many across Perth breathed a sigh of relief after Daryl's conviction for the horrific murder, those who knew him well were uneasy. Although Darryl was a convicted sex offender, there was a belief that these crimes had stemmed from his childlike manner and repressed curiosity about sex. He wasn't known to be at all violent or aggressive, as Gillian's killer clearly was. It turned out that there had always been issues with Darryl's confession.
他最初因杀害吉莉安·布鲁尔被判处死刑。然而，这一判决随后被减为终身监禁，比米什最终在服刑15年后获释。虽然珀斯的许多人在达里尔因这起可怕的谋杀案被定罪后松了一口气，但那些了解他的人却感到不安。尽管达里尔是一名被定罪的性犯罪者，但人们认为这些罪行源于他孩子气的举止和对性压抑的好奇心。他并不以暴力或好斗著称，而吉莉安的杀手显然是这样。事实证明，达里尔的供词一直存在问题。
He hadn't accurately described the injuries to Jillian's body, said he had raped her despite no evidence of sexual assault, and even named the wrong day the attack had taken place. Journalist Estelle Blackburn's friend and colleague, Brett Christian, of Post Newspapers turned his focus to Daryl Beamish's case in his own book, Presumed Guilty. He described how Daryl had difficulty communicating with police officers due to being deaf and non-verbal. He repeatedly got facts wrong about Gillian's case, including saying he'd fled her flat via the back door, which was locked from the inside when the crime scene was discovered. The lead detective had also taken Darryl to Jillian's home and lay on her bed,
他没有准确描述吉莉安身体上的伤口，声称强奸了她，尽管没有性侵犯的证据，甚至说错了袭击发生的日期。记者埃斯特尔·布莱克本的朋友兼同事、《邮报》的布雷特·克里斯蒂安在他的书《推定有罪》（Presumed Guilty）中将焦点转向了达里尔·比米什的案件。他描述了达里尔由于耳聋和非语言交流障碍，在与警官沟通时遇到的困难。他反复在吉莉安案件的事实上出错，包括说他从后门逃离了她的公寓，而当犯罪现场被发现时，后门是从里面锁上的。首席侦探还曾带达里尔去吉莉安的家，并躺在她的床上，
miming how she had been stabbed in various parts of her body by making chopping motions with his hands. parts of her body by making chopping motions with his hands. Darrell had apparently nodded as the detective did this, which was taken as a confession. In contrast, Eric Edgar Cook's confession aligned perfectly with the details of the case. He overheard part of Gillian's conversation with her fiancé, which her fiancé was able to confirm was most likely correct. Evidence also linked him to her home at the Brookwood Flats well before her murder and a burglary of Gillian's mother's home next door. In 2005, three years after John Button was exonerated, Darryl Beamish had his conviction overturned as well. He was awarded $425,000 compensation by the state government. Although Eric Edgar Cook apologised to John Button and Darryl Beamish for their wrongful
用手做出砍劈的动作，模仿她身体各部位是如何被刺伤的。达里尔显然在侦探这样做时点了点头，这被视为供词。相比之下，埃里克·埃德加·库克的供词与案件细节完全吻合。他无意中听到了吉莉安与未婚夫谈话的一部分，她的未婚夫能够证实这很可能是正确的。证据还将他与她谋杀前很久在布鲁克伍德公寓的家以及隔壁吉莉安母亲家的入室盗窃案联系起来。2005年，在约翰·巴顿平反三年后，达里尔·比米什的定罪也被推翻。他获得了州政府42.5万澳元的赔偿。尽管埃里克·埃德加·库克在处决前向约翰·巴顿和达里尔·比米什为他们的错误
convictions prior to his execution, the Western Australia police force never has. Much of the blame for the wrongful convictions has been placed on a former detective named Owen Leach. He was the officer who extracted a confession from Darryl Beamish and his solving of Gillian Brewer's high-profile murder directly led to him being promoted to the top position of Western Australia's Police Commissioner. Leach was also responsible for convicting another deaf man who was friends with Darrell Beamish for a burglary and assault committed by Eric Edgar Cooke. The victim's description of her attacker matched Coo Cook exactly, but Leach instead pinned it on an innocent man who was taller than Cook and looked nothing like him.
定罪表示道歉，但西澳大利亚州警察部队从未这样做。造成错误定罪的大部分责任被归咎于一位名叫欧文·里奇的前侦探。正是这名警官从达里尔·比米什那里提取了供词，而他侦破吉莉安·布鲁尔这起备受瞩目的谋杀案，直接导致他被提升为西澳大利亚州警察局长的最高职位。里奇还负责将另一名与达里尔·比米什是朋友的聋哑人定罪，罪名是埃里克·埃德加·库克犯下的入室盗窃和袭击罪。受害者对袭击者的描述与库克完全吻合，但里奇却将其归咎于一个比库克高、长相完全不像他的无辜者。
In the documentary series After the Night, former Western Australia Premier Brian Burke said that in his experience Owen Leach intimidated other officers and was, quote, "...a frightening person to deal with." There was no one more fervent in his efforts to keep innocent people in jail. One of Leach's detectives, who was directly responsible for Cook ultimately confessing to the Australia Day attacks, admitted to driving Cook past Gillian Brewer's home after his arrest. His hope was that Cook would admit to the murder, which the detective didn't believe Beamish was responsible for. John Button and Darrell Beamish were just two of Eric Edgar Cook's living victims whose lives were permanently altered and damaged.
在纪录片系列《夜幕之后》（After the Night）中，前西澳大利亚州州长布莱恩·伯克表示，根据他的经验，欧文·里奇恐吓其他警官，引用他的话说是“……一个令人恐惧的人”。没有人比他更热衷于将无辜者关进监狱。里奇的一名侦探，即最终促使库克承认澳大利亚日袭击事件的直接负责人，承认在库克被捕后开车带他经过吉莉安·布鲁尔的家。他的希望是库克能承认谋杀，而这位侦探并不认为比米什应对此负责。约翰·巴顿和达里尔·比米什只是埃里克·埃德加·库克的幸存受害者中的两位，他们的生活被永久地改变和破坏了。
Cooke's own family were victims of him as well. He kept up a facade with his wife, Sally, while also spending copious amounts of time away from her and their children. Sally was never allowed to ask her husband questions about what he got up to at night or query his frequent absences from home. She believed her husband was cheating on her, as strange women often came to their house looking for Cook. He had told them Sally was his widowed sister and he was helping to raise her children. In the aftermath of the Australia Day shootings, Cook acted as though his family needed to fear the nightcaller the same as everyone else. In the documentary series After the Night,
库克自己的家人也是他的受害者。他在妻子萨莉面前维持着一种假象，同时又花费大量时间远离她和他们的孩子。萨莉从不允许问丈夫晚上在做什么，也不允许询问他频繁离家的情况。她以为丈夫在外面有外遇，因为经常有陌生的女人来家里找库克。他告诉她们萨莉是他守寡的妹妹，他正在帮忙抚养她的孩子。在澳大利亚日枪击事件发生后，库克表现得好像他的家人也需要像其他人一样害怕“夜间来电者”。在纪录片系列《夜幕之后》中，
Sally Cook told the filmmakers how Cook had insisted their children no longer sleep outside during the summer. They all had to sleep on the bedroom floor next to her instead. He'd demand that she lock all the doors to stay safe while he was out prowling the streets of Perth. He came up with his own special knock and whistle so when he returned home after a long night out she would know it was him outside. When he arrived home, Sally quickly pulled him inside and said, I hate this killer on the loose. When are they going to catch him? The date that Cook was finally arrested for murder in 1963 was Father's Day. When there was a knock at the Cook residence later that morning, the children all raced down the
萨莉·库克告诉电影制作人，库克坚持要求他们的孩子夏天不再睡在外面。他们都必须睡在卧室地板上，紧挨着她。他要求她锁好所有的门以确保安全，而他则出去在珀斯的街道上徘徊。他想出了自己特殊的敲门声和口哨声，这样当他在漫长的夜晚外出归来时，她就会知道是他在外面。当他回到家时，萨莉迅速把他拉进屋里说：“我讨厌这个逍遥法外的杀手。他们什么时候才能抓住他？”库克最终因谋杀罪被捕的日期是1963年的父亲节。那天早上晚些时候，当库克家传来敲门声时，孩子们都拿着礼物冲向
hallway with presents in their hands, expecting to greet their father. Instead, they were met by police officers who'd come to inform Sally Cook of her husband's arrest. The news of what he was charged with had come as an enormous shock. As Sally Cooke stated in After the Night, quote, I knew he was a thief and a womaniser, but that's far different to being a murderer. The family also had to grapple with what might have happened to them if police hadn't managed to arrest Cooke first. He admitted to detectives that he'd been keeping a rifle and ammunition in the ceiling of his home and intended to kill his wife, children, and finally himself if it ever seemed the police were closing in. I wasn't going to leave them
走廊，期待着迎接他们的父亲。然而，迎接他们的是前来通知萨莉·库克她丈夫被捕的警察。他被指控的消息令人震惊。正如萨莉·库克在《夜幕之后》中所述，引用：“我知道他是个小偷和花花公子，但这与成为杀人犯完全不同。”家人还不得不面对如果警察没有先设法逮捕库克，他们可能会发生什么。他向侦探承认，他一直把一支步枪和弹药藏在家里天花板上，如果警察看起来快要包围他，他打算杀死妻子、孩子，最后自杀。“我不会把他们
behind for anybody else, he stated. Sally Cook was left with no money and had to survive on a pension while raising seven children all alone. Her siblings would no longer associate with her due to the social stigma. Despite this, Sally refused to leave Perth, explaining that she wanted to teach her children that painful experiences had to be met and confronted head on. In After the Night, Sally described how proud she was of her seven children, stating, "...my family could have been a lot different to what they were. Not one of them took after him."
留给任何人，”他陈述道。萨莉·库克身无分文，不得不靠养老金独自抚养七个孩子。由于社会污名，她的兄弟姐妹不再与她来往。尽管如此，萨莉拒绝离开珀斯，解释说她想教导孩子们，痛苦的经历必须直面和应对。在《夜幕之后》中，萨莉描述了她对七个孩子感到多么自豪，并表示：“……我的家庭本可能与现在大不相同。他们中没有一个人像他。”
were. Not one of them took after him. The couple's eldest child, Tony Cook, became a highly regarded social worker and later a union leader who fought for workers' rights. In 2002, he and his mother met with John Button and the parents of Rosemary Anderson to apologise for his father's crimes. This meeting was covered in an episode of the ABC television programme Australian Story. When asked in a televised interview about how his father's crimes had shaped his life, Tony answered, I'd have to say it has made a huge impact on me as a person. It guides me in what I do.
他们中没有一个人像他。这对夫妇的长子托尼·库克成为了一名备受尊敬的社会工作者，后来成为了一名争取工人权利的工会领袖。2002年，他和母亲会见了约翰·巴顿和罗斯玛丽·安德森的父母，为他父亲的罪行道歉。这次会面被ABC电视节目《澳大利亚故事》（Australian Story）的一集报道。当在电视采访中被问及他父亲的罪行如何塑造了他的人生时，托尼回答说：“我不得不说，这对我个人产生了巨大的影响。它指导着我的所作所为。”
It's formed my values and my attitudes. It's given me the conviction that what I should be doing is working towards a more positive society, the sort of society that doesn't breed people like my father." Tony Cook passed away in 2018, followed by his mother Sally one year later in 2019. The victims of Cook's attacks who survived were also changed forever by what was done to them. also changed forever by what was done to them. Some suffered permanent or temporary physical disabilities and brain damage. Many battled post-traumatic stress in the months and years after their assaults. Their goals and ambitions changed, some relocated and moved away from their homes. A sense of safety, freedom, and security was taken from them. Even victims of Cook's burglaries who had no idea they'd been robbed until later notified by the police have had to
它塑造了我的价值观和态度。它让我坚信，我应该做的是致力于一个更积极的社会，那种不会滋生像我父亲这样的人的社会。”托尼·库克于2018年去世，他的母亲萨莉于一年后的2019年去世。库克袭击的幸存受害者也因所遭受的一切而永远改变了。有些人遭受了永久性或暂时性的身体残疾和脑损伤。许多人在遭受袭击后的几个月和几年里与创伤后应激障碍作斗争。他们的目标和抱负改变了，有些人搬迁并离开了家园。安全感、自由和保障被从他们身上夺走了。即使是库克入室盗窃的受害者，在后来被警方通知之前根本不知道自己被抢劫过，也必须
live with knowing they'd had a close brush with the notorious murderer. Others faced different battles when they realised they would never get their day in court. According to Estelle Blackburn's book, Broken Lives, hit and run victim Jill Connell only realised who was behind her attack after her mother read an early headline about how Cook had lived nearby. She immediately suspected he must have been Jill's attacker and followed it up with the police. The police confirmed their suspicions and Jill was overjoyed to finally know what had happened to her. However, her relief turned to despair when investigators told her Cook would not be trialed for her crime. Jill wanted the vindication of a public trial so everyone would know who had
带着知道自己曾与臭名昭著的杀人犯擦肩而过的认知生活。其他人意识到他们永远无法在法庭上讨回公道时，面临着不同的战斗。根据埃斯特尔·布莱克本的书《破碎的生活》，肇事逃逸受害者吉尔·康奈尔在她的母亲读到一篇关于库克住在附近的早期头条新闻后，才意识到是谁在背后袭击了她。她立即怀疑他一定是吉尔的袭击者，并向警方跟进。警方证实了他们的怀疑，吉尔欣喜若狂，终于知道了发生在她身上的事情。然而，当调查人员告诉她库克不会因她的罪行受审时，她的宽慰变成了绝望。吉尔想要一场公开审判的平反，这样每个人都会知道是谁
hurt her. The hit and run left Jill with significant scarring, physical pain, and emotional trauma. When she initially told her friends that her case was solved and Cook was responsible, they hadn't believed her. This further traumatised victims like Jill, who were left with a feeling of injustice. Journalist Estelle Blackburn has argued that police never publicised Cook's confessions about assaulting women in their homes because they didn't want the public to make the connection between Cook and Gillian Brewer's murder. This was in keeping with their decision to keep Cook's hit and runs a secret so he wouldn't be suspected of Rosemary Anderson's murder. Just as she had done with those cases, Estelle Blackburn
伤害了她。那次肇事逃逸给吉尔留下了严重的疤痕、身体疼痛和情感创伤。当她最初告诉朋友她的案件已破，库克是罪魁祸首时，他们并不相信她。这进一步伤害了像吉尔这样的受害者，她们感到一种不公正。记者埃斯特尔·布莱克本认为，警方从未公开库克关于在受害者家中袭击女性的供词，因为他们不想让公众将库克与吉莉安·布鲁尔的谋杀案联系起来。这与他们决定对库克的肇事逃逸保密以使他不被怀疑是罗斯玛丽·安德森的谋杀者是一致的。正如她对那些案件所做的那样，埃斯特尔·布莱克本
tracked down the survivors who had been assaulted in their homes. One of these was Molly McLeod, who had been 15 years old when Cook hit her over the head while robbing her family's home, concussing her. For 30 years, the McLeod family had believed Molly had simply fallen out of bed, until Estelle Blackburn uncovered Cook's confession and reached out to Molly's father. Police hadn't just concealed Cook's non-fatal crimes. For years, they had believed that Cook's first murder victim, Penina Berkman, was killed by her boyfriend who subsequently left Australia for Greece. After Cook provided a highly detailed admission to the crime, they accepted that he was the true culprit. But they never charged him with Penina's murder, and nor did they notify any of her family members
追踪到了那些在家中遭到袭击的幸存者。其中一位是莫莉·麦克劳德，她在15岁时，库克在抢劫她家时击中她的头部，导致她脑震荡。30年来，麦克劳德一家一直以为莫莉只是从床上摔了下来，直到埃斯特尔·布莱克本发现了库克的供词并联系了莫莉的父亲。警方不仅隐瞒了库克的非致命罪行。多年来，他们一直认为库克的第一个谋杀受害者佩尼娜·伯克曼是被她的男友杀害的，该男友随后离开澳大利亚去了希腊。在库克对该罪行提供了极其详细的供述后，他们承认他是真正的罪魁祸首。但他们从未以佩尼娜的谋杀罪起诉他，也没有通知她的任何家人
that the case was solved. At the time of her murder in 1959, Penina had an eight-year-old son named Mark. She and Mark had relocated to Perth from Melbourne after Panina and her Polish-born husband divorced. On the night of his mother's murder, Mark had been staying at a friend's house for the school holidays. He never understood the truth of what happened to his mother, and the next four years of Mark's life remain a blur to this day. His father took Mark back to Melbourne and the pair later relocated to Israel. In the documentary series, After the Night, Mark described his grief as follows. All of a sudden you lose a mother. One day you see her, the next day you don't. And you don't know
案件已破。在1959年她被谋杀时，佩尼娜有一个八岁的儿子名叫马克。在佩尼娜和她波兰裔丈夫离婚后，她和马克从墨尔本搬到了珀斯。在他母亲被谋杀的那天晚上，马克正住在朋友家过寒假。他从未理解母亲身上到底发生了什么，而马克接下来四年的生活至今仍是一片模糊。他的父亲把马克带回了墨尔本，两人后来搬到了以色列。在纪录片系列《夜幕之后》中，马克这样描述他的悲伤：“突然之间你失去了一个母亲。有一天你见到她，第二天你就不再见到她了。而你不知道
the reason, and it doesn't really matter. I see it as a private holocaust. It only belongs to me. In 2004, Mark visited Australia to see some extended family members. In 2004, Mark visited Australia to see some extended family members. A cousin told him about the book Broken Lives and how it told his mother's story. Mark got hold of a copy and was stunned to learn the truth. It was the first he'd ever heard about what happened to his mother and who was responsible for taking her life. The family members and friends of Cook's seven other murder victims have been dealt a life sentence as well. Countless individuals have had to grave loved ones under the most painful
原因，这其实并不重要。我把它看作是一场私人的大屠杀。它只属于我。”2004年，马克访问澳大利亚看望了一些远房亲戚。一位表亲告诉他关于《破碎的生活》这本书，以及它是如何讲述他母亲的故事的。马克弄到了一本，得知真相后感到震惊。这是他第一次听说母亲身上发生了什么，以及是谁夺走了她的生命。库克的其他七名谋杀受害者的家人和朋友也受到了终身监禁的惩罚。无数人不得不在最痛苦的
circumstances and live in a new reality that was far more terrifying than the one they knew before. This loss of innocence was felt more broadly by the entire city of Perth, which was fundamentally different after Cook. Even though Cook's crimes are now more than 60 years old, some long-time residents still have first-hand memories of his reign of terror. As Estelle Blackburn stated in the 2020 documentary After the Night, quote, All these years on, there are still all these people who carried the scars of the crimes of Eric Edgar Cook. Far more people than we realised at the time, really affected by his attacks.
情况下埋葬亲人，并生活在一个比他们以前所知的现实远为恐怖的新现实中。这种纯真的丧失被整个珀斯市更广泛地感受到，在库克之后，这座城市发生了根本性的变化。尽管库克的罪行现在已经过去60多年了，但一些老居民仍然对他的恐怖统治有第一手的记忆。正如埃斯特尔·布莱克本在2020年的纪录片《夜幕之后》中所述，引用：“这么多年过去了，仍然有这么多人带着埃里克·埃德加·库克罪行的伤疤。比我们当时意识到的要多得多的人，真的受到了他袭击的影响。”
Their families, their friends, there are a lot of people still in Perth who sleep with a light on at night. Music Music Music Can artificial intelligence be a force for good? At the University of British Columbia, we believe it can. Dr. Raymond Ng and team are using AI to harness crucial data within the health care system to help deliver care to patients faster. It's AI that puts our health first. At UBC, our researchers are answering today's most pressing questions. To learn how we're moving the world forward, visit ubc.ca slash forward happens here. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
他们的家人，他们的朋友，珀斯还有很多人晚上睡觉时开着灯。音乐 音乐 音乐 人工智能可以成为一股向善的力量吗？在不列颠哥伦比亚大学，我们相信可以。雷蒙德·吴博士和他的团队正在利用人工智能来利用医疗保健系统中的关键数据，以帮助更快地为患者提供护理。这是将我们的健康放在首位的人工智能。在UBC，我们的研究人员正在回答当今最紧迫的问题。要了解我们如何推动世界前进，请访问ubc.ca斜杠forward happens here。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。